schönen guten Tag meine Damen und Herren
es war in der Tat ein einzigartiger
Vorgang den wir da erlebt haben im
Oktober das Machtwort des Bundeskanzlers
war ja nichts anderes als die Ausübung
seiner Richtlinienkompetenz er hat dann
einen weisen Mittelweg gewählt die
Bündnisgrünen wollten ja eigentlich die
Atomkraft zum 31.12 auslaufen lassen
haben danach gebessert dass ganze hätte
dann also als vorratsreserve dienen
sollen zwei südliche AKWs bis zum April
die FDP hat dagegen gehalten hat gesagt
nein wir brauchen in der jetzigen
Situation jede Energie die wir
gebrauchen die wir holen können und
deswegen war die FDP sogar dafür die
drei Atomkraftwerke auch noch zwei Jahre
laufen zu lassen in Deutschland der
Kanzler hat dann bekanntlich den
Mittelweg vorgegeben die Atomkraftwerke
alle drei werden in einen streckbetrieb
gehen und am 15 April soll dann Schluss
sein mit der Atomkraft ganz wichtig ist
sollen keine neuen Brennstäbe gekauft
werden das ist der Kompromiss um den es
heute geht eigentlich muss man natürlich
sagen eine Verlängerung der Laufzeiten
nämlich bis zum 15.4 muss der Bundestag
heute beschließen mit der Mehrheit der
Ampel und so wird es dann
voraussichtlich auch kommen aber ich
kann mal nachfragen bei meinen heutigen
Gästen ich begrüße ganz herzlich Harald
Ebner er ist der Vorsitzende des
Ausschusses für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz und Steffen Bilger
begrüße ich den stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-fraktion für diesen Bereich
zuständig Herr Bürger ich habe es gerade
so ein bisschen
Herr Ebner ich habe es gerade so ein
bisschen beschrieben wie sauer sind die
Grünen eigentlich noch auf den
Bundeskanzler
wir sind gar nicht sauer aber lassen Sie
mich eins sagen weil sie sagen die
Grünen wollten zum 31.12 Schluss mit der
Atomenergie machen das waren
einstimmiger Beschluss des Deutschen
Bundestages im Juni 2011 also die ganze
Republik der gesamte Bundestages war
einstimmig es waren
gesellschaftspolitischer Konsens ein
gesellschaftlicher Konsens zum 31.12
diesen Jahres aus der Atomenergie
auszusteigen und das ist bis jetzt
geltende Rechtslage richtig aber dann
kam der Krieg und die Probleme die damit
einhergehen und deswegen noch mal die
Frage damit was gleich mal festmachen
werden die Grünen denn heute dieser
Verlängerung der Laufzeit bis zum April
zustimmen es wird für uns ja nicht
einfach wir hatten eine Notfallreserve
für zwei Kraftwerke im Süden das wäre
auch sachgerecht gewesen was die Energie
technischen Fragen angeht vorgesehen
wir tun uns schwer mit jedem Tag den die
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen wir können
aber gut damit leben dass keine neuen
Brennstäbe das ist für uns die rote
Linie dass keine neuen Brennstäbe
beschafft werden dass kein neuer
Atommüll anfällt weil die Endlagersuche
ist bis heute ungelöst insoweit tragen
wir die heute zur Abstimmung stehende
Lösung den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung mit man merkt den Grünen
fällt das erkennbar schwer logisches ist
ja eine Art gründungs DNA gegen
Atomkraft zu sein die Union sieht das
ein bisschen anders sie sagt wir haben
eine Notlage wir wollen die AKWs länger
laufen lassen nämlich bis zum 31.12 24
warum dieser Termin und ihnen ist schon
klar das haben sie auch reingeschrieben
dass sie neue Brennstäbe brauchen und da
sagen viele Experten also wenn man neue
Brennstäbe einsetzt dann müssen die auch
mindestens drei vier Jahre besser
brennen warum also 24 Ende
wir sind in einer Energiekrise und ich
glaube allen ist bewusst dass wir da
wirklich vom großen Problem stehen
deswegen hat die Ampel sich auch
durchgerungen zu diesem Minimalkonsens
zumindest die Laufzeiten bis April zu
verlängern um über diesen Winter zu
kommen aber das wird nicht reichen denn
der kommende Winter darauf folgende
Winter 23 24 wird voraussichtlich noch
härter werden also dieser Minimalkonsens
in der Regierung reicht nicht aus in der
Tat der große Unterschied zwischen den
beiden Gesetzentwürfen die heute zur
Abstimmung stehen wir plädieren dafür
neue Brennstäbe zu beschaffen die
Laufzeiten mindestens bis Ende 24 zu
verlängern wir haben in unserem
Gesetzentwurf auch eine Evaluierung
vorgesehen das sind dann im Sommer 24
überprüft ob ein nochmalige Verlängerung
nötig ist wir stehen zum Atomausstieg
aber ich glaube in der jetzigen
Situation es ist einfach nicht
verantwortungsbewusst aus politischen
Gründen diese Option wegzugeben wo wir
nicht wissen ob wir wirklich
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten
können wo die Strompreise viel zu hoch
sind wo es auch um eine Frage der
europäischen Solidarität und nicht
zuletzt auch um den Klimaschutz geht
dann viel Kohle zu verfeuern statt die
Kernkraftwerke am Netz zu lassen das
macht ja wirklich nicht so richtig Sinn
erinner ich zitiere mal die
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke von den
Grünen aus der ersten Lesung am Mittwoch
sie hat gesagt es wäre absolut
fahrlässig auf diesen Beitrag zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt zu verzichten diese
drei AKWs das ist an Erkenntnis die hat
sie nicht das ganze Jahr über gehabt und
diese Erkenntnis ist ja auch eine die
die anderen oppositionsverteilen teilen
und sagen deswegen brauchen wir das
wahrscheinlich auch noch im kommenden
Winter wo ist da der Unterschied zum
Winter 23 und da wird ja einiges
ausgeblendet also zum einen die
Erkenntnis ist ja dem zweiten
verschärften Stresstest durch die
Netzbetreiber geschuldet die aber gesagt
hat im Grundsatz können diese drei
Atomkraftwerke kaum und maximal einen
marginalen Beitrag zur Netzstabilität
leisten und schon gar nicht zum
gaseinsparen und schon gar nicht was die
Preise angeht desto der erste Punkt der
der Unterschied zur Union ist dass wir
sagen
wir wollen dass die Kraftwerke zur
Verfügung stehen in dem Fall indem man
sie braucht das hat sich jetzt erledigt
durch den durch den Beschluss der
ansteht sie laufen durch bis zum 15.4
also ein begrenzter Weiterbetrieb bis
längstens 15.04 das ist ein wesentlicher
Unterschied und der der dritte Punkt
wenn ich die Krokodilstränen höre was
den Klimaschutz angeht bei der Union
dann frage ich mich einfach täglich
warum haben wir in den letzten 16
unionsgeführten Jahren in dieser
Republik nicht mehr Klimaschutz gesehen
nicht mehr ausbaut erneuerbaren Energien
und das genau ist das was wir jetzt in
diesem Jahr mit wirklich einer bislang
nie dagewesenen Geschwindigkeit auf den
Weg gebracht haben und das wird es auch
sein was uns dann in den und über den
nächsten Winter tragen wird sind sie
auch vorstellen wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass jetzt die Gasspeicher zu 100%
gefüllt sind
letzten Herbst waren die leer wir haben
ein Gesetz geschaffen das dafür sorgt
dass das passiert und wir haben es
geschafft obwohl die russischen
Gaslieferungen komplett ausgesetzt sind
und damit sorgen wir vor und damit
schaffen wir uns auch eine Sicherheit
für die kommenden Jahre weil da der
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren dann auch
massivfahrern kommen wird das Argument
kommt ja immer wieder in den letzten 16
Jahren ist zu wenig passiert man
bräuchte eigentlich mehr erneuerbare
Energie die hat man jetzt aber nicht und
interessanterweise hat man auch im
ersten halben Jahr unter der Ampel nicht
mehr Zubau an Windrädern zum Beispiel
als unter der großen Koalition woran
liegt das
ich muss zunächst mal Herrn Ebner
widersprechen also die Bundesregierung
will ja nicht mit mehr erneuerbaren
Energien durch diesen und den nächsten
Winter kommen sondern vor allem mit dem
wieder Anfeuern von kohlekraftwerten und
das hat mit Klimaschutz dann wirklich
nichts zu tun man kann darüber streiten
was wir bisher in Klimaschutz erreicht
haben in Deutschland muss allerdings
auch darauf hinweisen 1990 hat man sich
ein Ziel gesetzt den CO2-Ausstoß und 40%
zu reduzieren bis 2020 das haben wir
erreicht also wir haben durchaus einiges
geschafft als Industrienation wo wir
auch darauf achten müssen dass wir die
Versorgung mit Energie sicherstellen so
dass es für die Verbraucher zu
bezahlbaren Preis möglich ist und das
auch die Arbeitsplätze erhalten werden
ich komme aus Baden-Württemberg wir eben
auch hier im Bundestag wird immer den
Bayern und der CSU vorgehalten die
hätten nichts erreicht beim Ausbau der
Windkraft also in Baden-Württemberg in
elf Jahren grüne Umweltminister sieht es
auch nicht anders aus klar wir brauchen
eine Kraftanstrengung ist immer aber
auch wieder bei Themen wo die Grünen
gefördert sind weil bisher war es halt
oft so dass der Naturschutz oder andere
Fragen
schnelleren Ausbau
erneuerbaren Energien in Gegenständen
also da müssen dann auch die Grünen über
den Schatten springen der gipsbewegung
das begrüße ich auch sehr und wir sind
absolut dazu bereit nochmal einen
richtigen Schub zu geben beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien denn das ist ja
unser gemeinsames Ziel dass wir
irgendwann zu 100% erneuerbaren kommen
und die fossilen Energien nicht
benötigen und auch die Kernkraft nicht
mehr benötigen aber damals noch einen
Weg zu gehen aber ist das nicht auch ein
Grund warum die Bundesregierung und auch
die Grünen Ministerinnen und Minister in
der Bundesregierung jetzt sagen okay für
diesen Jahr für diesen Winter brauchen
wir noch Atomkraft auch weil man die
Erkenntnis gewonnen hat dass eben die
Kohlekraftwerke gar nicht so schnell ans
Netz gehen können
genau das ist ja der Punkt darauf habe
ich vorhin hingewiesen der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren wurde ja behindert in den
letzten 16 Jahren das ist aber jetzt in
diesem Winter links aus dieser
Erkenntnis heraus wir können ja nicht
Windräder einfach herzaubern weil sie
schon gesagt haben in den ersten sechs
Monaten ist da noch nichts passiert ich
meine sie haben einen Planungsvorlauf in
sechs Monaten bauen sie auch kein
Windrad so also das heißt wir haben
jetzt Hürden aus dem Weg geräumt die die
Union aufgebaut hat es waren wahnsinnig
viele Schikanen im Übrigen auch für die
binnen für die Windkraft an Land gerade
in Baden-Württemberg da kamen gar keine
Anträge mehr obwohl wir in
Baden-Württemberg das von der Union
damals geschaffene verhinderungsrecht
aufgehoben haben damit diese diese
windkraftplanung schneller vorankommen
kann so also vor diesem Hintergrund
haben wir gesagt wir müssen alles
beschleunigen was geht
die lng-terminals die geb werden auch
noch mal auf Kohle und Öl zurückgreifen
aber lassen Sie mich das auch sagen wir
müssen auch einsparen dazu gibt es auch
Incentives Anreize für die für die
Industrie und Vereinbarungen und ist
gerade heute morgen hat die
Bundesnetzagentur auch noch mal
mitgeteilt oder was gestern um also wie
viel eingespart wurde die Industrie ich
glaube zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent und
die Privathaushalte sogar fast 50
Prozent das muss man sich mal vorstellen
das ist eine unglaubliche Leistung die
wir da alle zusammen die die Menschen in
diesem Land alle zusammen hinbekommen
haben und in der Summe in der Summe sind
wir überzeugt dass wir mit diesen
Maßnahmen gut über den Winter kommen
dass wir mit diesen Maßnahmen auch nicht
unsere Klimaziele gefährden denn
gleichzeitig haben wir heute in der
ersten Lesung auch die Vereinbarung den
Kohleausstieg der Union um acht Jahre
vorzuziehen wir steigen acht Jahre
zumindest im Rheinischen Revier schon
mal acht Jahre vorher aus der Kohle aus
und damit bleiben bleiben Millionen
Tonnen Kohle im Boden und werden nicht
verfeuert das ist ein echter Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz Klimaziele nicht verfehlen
das ist ein gutes Stichwort denn gestern
gerade hat die deutsche Delegation viel
Kritik von internationalen Professoren
und Wissenschaftlern gekriegt für die
Tatsache dass hier LNG Terminals
aufgebaut werden bei der internationalen
konferenzumweltkonferenz das ist ja in
der Tat auch nicht so einfach mit diesen
g Terminals die sind jetzt erstaunlich
schnell aus dem Boden gestampft worden
das erste wird wohl schon kommende oder
ich glaube kommende Woche eingeweiht das
ist schneller als man in Deutschland die
erwarten konnte aber ganz ohne sind
diese lngs ja auch nicht es gibt großes
Unverständnis in Europa und in der Welt
über die aktuelle Energie- und
Klimapolitik dieser Bundesregierung also
Beamte aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium aus dem
Bundesumweltministerium haben in Entwurf
des prüfvermerks vom März zur Frage der
Weiternutzung der Atomkraft
angeschrieben wenn die Atomkraftwerke
weiter betrieben werden im
Leistungsbetrieb dann bedeutet das 25
bis 30 Millionen Tonnen CO2-Einsparung
pro Jahr das ist eine Riesensumme das
ist die Hälfte dessen was die
Landwirtschaft pro Jahr in
CO2-Emissionen verantwortlich ist und
das gibt man einfach weg macht
stattdessen mehr Kohle baut
lng-terminals wir unterstützen den Bau
der lng-terminalsweise aus unserer Sicht
nötig ist und unsere Energieversorgung
zu sichern wir müssen jetzt eben alles
tun damit die Verbraucher die Sicherheit
haben dass auch die Unternehmen die
Sicherheit haben aber solche
Entscheidungen Kernkraft abzuschalten
oder auch andere Fragen die wir zurzeit
diskutieren die Bundesregierung wollte
die Förderung für kleine
Wasserkraftwerke streichen sie wollte
die Möglichkeiten beim Biogas Deckeln
das sind alles seltsame Entscheidungen
wenn es eigentlich heißt es kommt auf
jede Kilowattstunde an und wir wollen
auch den Klimaschutz ernst nehmen Herr
Müller vielen Dank dass Sie daran es
klingelt nämlich und Sie müssen dringend
rein weil sie einer der ersten Redner
sind Herr Ebner da sind wir gespannt
wenn sie nur sagen Klimaschutz
ist sehr wichtig wir müssen gleichzeitig
aber die nukleare Sicherheit genauso ins
Kalkül ziehen und wenn wir uns etwas
einkaufen eine Kilowattstunde wir können
die uns nicht um jeden Preis einkaufen
nämlich nicht um den Preis eines
erhöhten nuklearen Risikos und den
vermeiden wir diesen Preis vermeiden wir
vielen Dank ja meine Damen und Herren
die Atomkraft birgt Gefahren das ist so
in der Tat und darauf weisen die Grünen
ja auch immer zurecht hin die Frage ist
halt wie werden die Wohnzimmer warm
bleiben woher kommt der Strom in diesen
angespannten Zeiten darum wird jetzt
gestritten werden hier im deutschen
Parlament hier in den nächsten Minuten
und dann kommt darüber die Abstimmung
Verlängerung der Laufzeiten der drei
noch am Netz befindlichen AKWs darum
geht es jetzt im Plenum ich gebe rein
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
allen einen schönen guten Morgen die
Sitzung ist der öffnet
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung
gratuliere ich nachträglich der Kollegin
Heike Bremer zu ihrem 60 geburtstag im
Namen des ganzen Hauses alles Gute
[Applaus]
ich teile Ihnen zu dem mit dass sich der
Ältestenrat in seiner gestrigen Sitzung
darauf verständigt hat während der
Haushaltsberatung vom 22 bis 25 November
wie üblich keine Befragung der
Bundesregierung keine Fragestunde und
keine aktuellen Stunden durchführt als
Präsenztage nach Paragraph 14 Absatz 1
des abgeordnetengesetzes werden die Tage
von Montag 21 November bis Freitag 25
November als Präsenztage festgelegt ich
sehe dazu keinen Widerspruch
dann verfahren wir so vielen Dank
ich rufe auf
die Tagesordnungspunkte 32A bis 32d
Beratung mehrerer Vorlagen zur Änderung
des Atomgesetzes zu dem Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung liegt ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu vor über den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung und über den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der cdu/csu
sowie über die Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen für die Aussprache
wurde eine Dauer von 68 Minuten
vereinbart ich eröffne nun die
Aussprache und zuerst hat das Wort für
die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Harald Ebner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch vor einem
Jahr hätte ich mir nicht träumen lassen
diese Rede hier zu halten und für mich
und meine Fraktion ist sie heutige
Änderung des Atomgesetzes eine schwere
Entscheidung meine große Tochter wurde
im Herbst 1985 geboren und der erste
Frühling den sie erlebt hat war der
Frühling der keiner war im April 1986
war radioaktiver Fallout in weiten
Teilen Europas der die Kinder zum
drinnen bleiben Zwang und kein krabbeln
im Freien auf dem Boden ermöglichte nach
der Reaktorkatastrophe von Tschernobyl
wurde noch deutlicher was fehlen schon
lange klar war Atomkraft ist keine
Lösung und sicher ist nur das Risiko
2001 war der rot-grüne Atomausstieg
geschafft aus dem Union und FDP 2010
wieder ausgestiegen sind aber nach
Fukushima hat dieser Bundestag
einstimmig erneut beschlossen endgültig
aus der Atomenergie auszusteigen und
diese Entscheidung war eine der
wichtigsten Entscheidungen der
Bundesrepublik nach der
Wiedervereinigung mit deren
gesellschaftlicher Großkonflikt
befriedet wurde
leider noch nicht endgültig den nach wie
vor ist die endlagefrage für den
hochradioaktiven Atommüll ungelöst und
der Zeitplan kann so wissen wir heute
nicht gehalten werden der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriff Russlands
auf die Ukraine stellt uns jetzt vor
neue Herausforderungen
erstens Protein setzt Energie als Waffe
ein und die Abhängigkeit von russischem
Gas die uns in uns in die uns 16 Jahre
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung gebracht
haben hat sie als fatal erwiesen es ist
so und obwohl die deutschen Gasspeicher
dank der Bemühungen des bmwk heute zu
nahezu 100% gefüllt sind müssen wir
weitere Maßnahmen zur Stabilisierung der
Energieversorgung in Betracht ziehen und
drittens die
Atomenergiepolitik unseres französischen
Nachbarn gefährdet die dortige
Energieversorgung massiv weil die Hälfte
der französischen Atomkraftwerke wegen
technischen mängels oder Wassermangel
stillstehen
das stellt auch unsere Energieversorgung
vor Herausforderungen denn damit erhöhen
sich auch die Deutschen stromexporte
nach Frankreich wir stellen uns diese
Herausforderung auf ganzer Linie zum
einen haben wir die 16-jährige Blockade
der Union der erneuerbaren Energien
aufgelöst den ausbauturbo eingelegt auf
allen Ebenen von Wind und Solarenergie
weil es aber nicht kurzfristig durch den
Winter hilft ergreifen wir zahlreiche
Maßnahmen zur Substitution russischen
Erdgases die sind alle schon gelangt
genannt und es ist gut dass wir zunächst
alle diese Register der
Energieversorgung gezogen haben statt
wie andere sofort auf die Atomkraft zu
schielen denn die aktuelle Energiekrise
hat nichts aber auch überhaupt gar
nichts an der Gefährlichkeit atomarer
Technologie geändert ganz im Gegenteil
sie hat uns deren Verwundbarkeit
deutlich vor Augen geführt
gerade wenn wir in die Ukraine sehen wo
Atomkraftwerke zu Angriffszielen werden
wissen wir doch jeder Tag länger bei der
Atomenergie ist ein Tag zu viel und der
Stresstest hat deutlich gezeigt dass die
drei zu Rede stehenden AKWs nur wenig
zur Stabilisierung beitragen können
gerade deshalb wäre die Vorhaltung als
Notfallreserve wie wir sie ursprünglich
vorgeschlagen haben eine angemessene
Lösung gewesen und das Atomkraftwerk
Emsland trägt nun gar nichts dazu bei
ist auch energetisch kontraproduktiv was
in Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
angeht
die heutige Lösung mit sofortigen
streckbetrieb für alle drei
Atomkraftwerke bis längstens 15.04
entspricht dem nur in Teilen wir können
sie aber aus folgenden Gründen mittragen
erstens es bleibt beim Atomausstieg
zweitens
es werden es werden keine neuen
Brennelemente beschafft und damit auch
kein neues Risikomaterial und keine
Grundlage für weitere Verlängerungen
die Union die Union legt uns hier was
vor den Ausstieg aus dem Atomausstieg
alle zwei Jahre wollen sie eine
Laufzeitverlängerung machen sie nehmen
dabei das dadurch entstehende Risiko
billigend in Kauf
und wie sieht es in Kauf nehmen haben
wir gesehen mit ihrem Sachverständigen
in der Anhörung der in Bezug auf den
Betrieb von Atomkraftwerken gesagt hat
wo gehobelt wird fallen Späne
Atomkraftwerke sind keine Hobelmaschinen
und den Atommüll können Sie auch nicht
unter den Teppich kehren
meine Damen und Herren ich komme zum
Schluss die zeitlich befristete
Erweiterung des Leistungsbetriebs ist
für mich und die meisten Mitglieder
meiner Fraktion eine Zumutung aber wir
muten uns das zu weil der Atomausstieg
damit bestehen bleibt und weil es im
Gegensatz zum Entwurf der Union keine
Laufzeitverlängerung gibt und keine
neuen bremsstäbe und weil wir keine
Abstriche bei der nuklearensicherheit
machen das Wort des Kanzlers ist auch
unseres am 15.4 ist Schluss dankeschön
meine Damen und Herren wer Phoenix guckt
der hat einen Informationsvorsprung
Harald Ebner mein Interview Gast von
eben hatte eben das Wort und sich ein
nächste ist der andere Interview das
Steffen billiger von der Union und
Kollegen und lieber Herr Ebner sie reden
mir zu viel über die Vergangenheit sie
reden nicht wirklich über die Zukunft
sie reden vielleicht wie wir über den
Winter kommen wollen über diesen Winter
aber sie haben nichts dazu gesagt wie
wir über den darauffolgenden Winter
kommen sollen denn da stellen sich die
Probleme noch viel mehr da fehlen ihre
Antworten liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen von
den Grünen auf der einen Seite steht
heute der Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung
ein Minimalkonsens
Ergebnis einer zermürbenden monatelangen
Debatte innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
beendet durch ein inszeniertes Machtwort
des Bundeskanzlers und ich sage es ganz
deutlich ein weiterlaufen der
Kernkraftwerke bis Mitte April 23 bringt
zu wenig bringt zu wenig
Versorgungssicherheit auch mit Blick
eben auf den übernächsten Winter es
bringt zu wenig preisliche Entlastung
für Verbraucher und Unternehmen und es
ist auch zu wenig europäische
Solidarität das ganze ist ein zu wenig
Gesetzentwurf
auf der anderen Seite steht der
Gesetzentwurf von CDU und CSU der ist
eine angemessene und maßvolle Antwort
auf die gegenwärtige Energiekrise es
bleibt beim Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie
aber die Laufzeiten werden bis Ende über
nächsten Jahres verlängert das schafft
Versorgungssicherheit das senkt die
Strompreise das hilft der gesamten
europäischen Energieversorgung unser
Vorschlag ersparte Atmosphäre zu dem
viele Millionen Tonnen CO2 zusätzlich
die diese Bundesregierung mit dem wieder
hochfahren der Kohlekraftwerke
offensichtlich in Kauf nimmt unser
Gesetzentwurf das ist deshalb ein genau
richtig gesetzt
jetzt kamen hier ein paar Zwischenrufe
was denn mit der Endlager Thematik sein
die Anhörung im Umweltausschuss hat klar
ergeben dass ein Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke vorübergehend absolut
verantwortbar ist auch im Hinblick auf
die Endlagerung es geht jetzt um die
richtige Antwort in dieser Energiekrise
meine Damen und
weil die Sache ja eigentlich so klar ist
ist die Meinung der Menschen auch ganz
klassisch Stützen unseren Kurs eines
befristeten Weiterbetriebs und die
Menschen in unserem Land haben kein
Verständnis für ihr parteipolitisches
Taktieren meine Damen und Herren
ich will auch deutlich an die Adresse
der FDP sagen dieser Entscheidung heute
zwischen klaren Alternativen kann
niemand ausweichen auch nicht die
Abgeordneten der FDP wer jetzt nicht für
eine echte Laufzeitverlängerung stimmt
wer jetzt nicht für die Beschaffung
neuer Brennelemente stimmt der nimmt
billigend in Kauf dass Deutschland in
der Energiekrise ein noch größeres
Energieproblem bekommt
und deswegen sage ich auch klipp und
klar diese Bundesregierung dieser grüne
Energieminister diese grüne
Umweltministerin tragen die
Verantwortung dafür wenn Deutschland
nicht gut durch diesen und den nächsten
Winter kommt und wenn die Lichter
ausgehen dann werden Sie dafür die
politischen Konsequenzen tragen müssen
Herr Habeck und Frau Lemke
20 von 24 Jahren mit der SPD bitte mal
auch vor der eigenen Haustüren sie
tragen jetzt schon die Verantwortung für
unnötig hohe Energiepreise bis zu 14
Prozent höhere Stromkosten
prognostizieren Experten ohne eine echte
Laufzeitverlängerung und beim Anblick
des Stromrechnung kann sich dann jeder
Verbraucher da kann sich jeder
Unternehmer bei dieser Bundesregierung
dafür bedanken und weil diese
Ampelkoalition
viel zu lang haben sie für ihren
Minimalkonsens gebraucht Niedersachsen
Wahl grünen Parteitag sonstige
Befindlichkeiten so kann man ein Land
nicht durch eine Krise führen meine
Damen und Herren
Minister Habeck hat ja kürzlich
öffentlich die Arbeitsbelastung seiner
Mitarbeitenden Ministerium beklagt da
habe ich gedacht respektable Geste ein
Mitarbeiter der auch an seine Leute
denkt mir war aber nicht klar dass es in
Wahrheit ja ganz anders das ist schlimm
ist in diesem Ministerium die Fachleute
arbeiten hat aber offensichtlich auch
für die Tonne zumindest dann wenn es
nicht in die grüne parteiprogrammatik
passt das zeigt der sogenannte
Prüfvermerk den bundeswirtschafts- und
Umweltministerium im März angeblich
ergebnisoffen und ohne ideologische
Denkverbote in wenigen Tagen erstellt
haben heute wissen wir das war eine
politische Auftragsarbeit vom Gegenteil
hat uns die Bundesumweltministerin auch
vorgestern bei der regierungsbefragung
nicht überzeugen können Antworten auch
berechtigte Fragen zu Transparenz und
Objektivität fehlanzeige
stellt sich klar heraus wichtige Aspekte
wie der Strompreis der Klimaschutz wurde
bewusst ausgeblendet und noch schlimmer
nicht ins Konzept passende Meinungen
wurden rausgestrichen von Fachbeamten in
Entwurf geschriebene Fakten wurden
rausgestrichen zum Beispiel dass wir mit
dem Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke 25
bis 30 Millionen Tonnen CO2 pro Jahr
einsparen können das scheint bei den
Grünen mittlerweile keine Rolle mehr zu
spielen
Herr Harbeck hat in einer
videogrußbotschaft zur Welt
Klimakonferenz gesagt beim Klimaschutz
geht es um das Überleben der Menschheit
die Weltgemeinschaft bewegen sich nicht
schnell genug es müssen endliche
Ergebnisse geliefert werden und so
weiter das passt noch nicht zusammen die
Welt belehren und gleichzeitig hier die
Kernkraftwerke abschalten
Kohlekraftwerke zusätzlich ans Netz
nehmen das versteht niemand das versteht
nicht mal Greta Thunberg meine Damen und
Herren ich bitte Sie um Zustimmung für
unseren Gesetzentwurf
Steffen billiger bittet um Zustimmung
die Union hat einen eigenen
Gesetzentwurf über den nachher auf
namentlich hier abgestimmt wird und die
Union möchte das neue bremsstäbe gekauft
werden und die drei am Netz befindlichen
AKWs bis zum
31.12.2024 Weiterlaufen nächster Redner
kommt aus der SPD Carsten Träger ist der
Sprecher für Umwelt Naturschutz und
nukleare Sicherheit
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deutschland steigt aus der Atomenergie
aus
in genau
135 Tagen ist es soweit und heute am
pulsemörtel
155 Mal werden wir noch wach dann wird
unser Land ein ganzes Stück sicherer
sein
ich weiß ja nicht was sie in diesen 15
April tun werden und bei einigen will
ich es auch gar nicht wissen ich werde
an diesem Tag meine Kinder und meine
Frau umarmen und mit einem Glas Sekt
anstoßen es ist ein Samstag das
gefährliche Kapitel der Kernspaltung zum
Zwecke der Stromerzeugung schließt sich
dann ein für alle Mal in Deutschland
und widerruflich
endgültig es bleibt beim Ausstieg aus
der domenergie damit ziehen wir einen
Schlussstrich und eine Debatte die uns
durch den Überfall von Putins Armeen auf
die freie Ukraine aufgedrängt wurde
niemand hätte in Deutschland noch
ernsthaft anatomausstiege rüttelt wenn
ich das Gas als Rückgrat unsere
Energieversorgung innerhalb weniger
Monate komplett ausgefallen wäre
seit dem arbeiten wir mit Hochdruck
daran diese Energieversorgung neu
aufzustellen und was Olaf Scholz gesagt
hat ist richtig wir müssen über diesen
Winter kommen wir beschleunigen deshalb
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien wir
kaufen fossile Energieträger in der
ganzen Welt wir lassen sogar unsere
Kohlekraftwerke länger im Netz wir bauen
flüssiggast terminals in Rekordzeit
inklusive der Infrastruktur im
Hinterland und wir debattieren eben auch
über den sogenannten streckbetrieb
und wir haben lange geprüft und ich
glaube es ist auch unsere Verantwortung
gewesen als Entscheider in diesem Land
dass wir uns diese Entscheidung eben
nicht leicht gemacht haben die üblichen
Verdächtigen haben es natürlich schon
vorher gewusst dass wir jetzt jahrelang
die Atomkraftwerke weiter betreiben
müssen aber die verantwortungsvolle-
[Musik]
die notwendige Zeit genommen und diesen
Stresstest durchgeführt und er wurde
nicht von den Ministerien durchgeführt
sondern von den Strom betreibenden
Versorgern von den
übertragungsnetzleistern
und am Ende kommt eine Entscheidung die
nicht jedem von uns schmeckt aber
insgesamt ist es richtig den
streckbetrieb den finden wir
verantwortbar und er wird einen Beitrag
dazu leisten dass wir über den Winter
kommen und deshalb beschließen wir heute
dass die restlichen Brennstäbe die in
den Kraftwerken schon sind dass die
insofern ertüchtigt werden dürfen und
bis zum Ende verbraucht werden dürfen
dieses Ende ist der 15 April das
beschließen wir heute nicht mehr und
nicht weniger
der Stresstest der Energiewirtschaft hat
geteilt gezeigt Atomkraft leistet nur
einen kleinen Teil wir wollen uns eben
bestmöglich vorbereiten die Atomkraft
leistet nicht mal einen Anteil zur
Strommenge die wir benötigen sondern sie
leistet einen Teil zur besseren
Verteilung dieses Stroms innerhalb
Deutschlands weil in Bayern zu wenig
Energie erzeugt wird und weil in Bayern
zu wenige Leitungen für den Transport
von norddeutschen Strom in die
energieintensiven Zentren des Landes zur
Verfügung stehen ja Herr Söder
hätten sie mal richtig für die Zukunft
Bayerns vorgesorgt dann bräuchten wir
den schreckbetrieb nicht machen Sie es
mit sich und ihrem Gewissen aus warum
sie nicht anders gehandelt haben
wir hoffen dass die hoch die
Risikotechnologie die dreieinhalb Monate
noch unfallfrei übersteht denn das muss
man auch mal ehrlich zu Ende denken was
ist denn wenn es nicht gelingt wenn wir
weil wir möglicherweise irgendwelche
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen hinausgezogen
haben uns dann doch mit der Frage
konfrontiert sehen dass ein hoffentlich
nicht eintreten aber was wäre denn wenn
dann doch ein Unfall passiert wer trägt
denn dann die Verantwortung dafür diese
Frage Herr Bürger haben sie nicht
gestellt und sie haben sie auch nicht
beantwortet ich glaube aus guten Gründen
genau sie werden derjenige sein der ist
an uns vorwirft das kann ich mir schon
vorstellen mit der Werberin Jahreszeit
haben wir es dann hoffentlich geschafft
es bleibt beim Atomausstieg wir steigen
ein für alle Mal aus dieser
hochrisikotechnologie aus und dann
können Sie sich von der Union auf den
Kopf stellen mit den Füßen wackeln dann
ist Schluss ein für allemal
und der Bürger naja
jetzt habe ich nur noch leider 13
Sekunden deswegen
spare ich mir die Replik auf ihre
Ausführungen ich bin froh dass wir heute
einen guten Beschluss fassen werden und
es dann dieses Kapitel ein für alle Mal
beendet ist vielen Dank
kassenträger von der SPD ist zufrieden
das ist mit der Atomkraft im April zu
Ende geht wir sollten bei dieser Debatte
mal darauf achten ob es hier nur um die
Frage geht dass die Atomkraft beendet
wird oder auch um die Frage wie wohl die
Wohnzimmer warm bleiben oder auch nicht
Thomas ehrhorn jetzt für die AFD frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren ich
beginne meine Rede mit zwei Zitaten
erstens Robert Habeck im Jahr 2016 geben
Sie uns noch zwei drei Monate dann
regieren wir diese Republik und dann
wird sich folgendes ändern wir werden
Nord Stream nicht bauen und die
Handelsbeziehungen des gasttransfers zu
Russland sukzessive abbauen weil wir ein
Energiewende Land sind zweites Zitat die
niedersächsische Fraktionschefin der
Grünen Julia williamborg im September
diesen Jahres es ist ein riesiger Erfolg
für die Bundesregierung dass Deutschland
seit 14 Tagen kein Gas mehr aus Russland
importiert was sagt uns das es zeigt uns
das ist schon vor fünf Jahren Bestand
der Grünen Pläne war die preiswerten
russischen gastlieferungen zu sabotieren
und deshalb zeigt es auch dass schon die
ersten einleitenden Sätze des
regierungsantrages falsch sind denn
nicht russland hat künstlich eine
gastnappheit geschaffen sondern sie auf
der Regierungsbank sind es die mit allen
Mitteln diese Lieferung verhindern
wollten und dies durch ihre irre
Sanktionspolitik auch erreicht haben sie
nutzen also ihre verlogene moralpolitik
als Rechtfertigung um ihre eigentlichen
Ziele zu erreichen und eigentlich sollte
es doch auch dem Dümmsten klar sein dass
wir nicht nur in diesem sondern auch in
den kommenden Wintern grundlastfähige
Kernkraftwerke brauchen werden und dass
uns deshalb ein zeitlich begrenzter
streckbetrieb nicht einen Meter
weiterbringt
das ist auch ein Trugschluss ist zu
glauben man müsse nur genügend Windräder
aufstellen dann könne man alles andere
abbauen wenn wir das machen geht halt
bei Flaute das Licht aus das ist doch so
schwer nicht zu verstehen meine Damen
und Herren es sei denn man baut auf den
Import von ausländischen Atom und
Kohlestrom und begibt sich dann
natürlich in die nächste fatale
Abhängigkeit wenn man dann auch noch
sagt Atomkraft erzeugt zwar kein CO2
wollen wir aber trotzdem nicht
Kohlekraft wollen wir mittelfristig auch
nicht weil es nämlich CO2 erzeugt und
preiswertes russisches Gas wollen wir
schon dreimal nicht weil wir gerne in
Ukraine Krieg zu unserem machen wollen
ja dann ist dies tatsächlich der direkte
Weg in die Zerstörung unserer
Industrienation und der Weg in die
Verarmung unserer Bevölkerung und genau
diesen Weg beschreiben wir ja auch und
deswegen fragen sich immer mehr Menschen
da draußen ob es wirklich denkbar ist
dass es hier eine überwiegend dumme
Politikerkaste einfach nur dumme
Entscheidungen trifft ich kann sie aber
da draußen beruhigen das ist eben genau
nicht so denn wer die tiefrote wieder
der Grünen Partei und ihre Akteure
durchdrungen hat der weiß dass
mindestens die ideologische
Führungselite ganz genau weiß was sie
tut und wohin der Weg eigentlich gehen
soll und einige sagen das inzwischen
ganz ungeniert ich zitiere die grüne
Wirtschaftsjournalistin der taz Ulrike
Herrmann die sich in einem Vortrag nicht
entblöden konnte folgendes zu sagen man
muss sich klar machen das Klimaschutz
den totalen Umbau bedeutet da bleibt
kein Stein auf dem anderen und dann ist
klar dass das grüne das ist das grüne
Wachstum nicht geben wird sondern was
wir haben werden ist grüne schrumpfen
wir müssen raus aus dem Kapitalismus
eine staatlich gelenkte Privatwirtschaft
plus Rationierung
das ist die Zukunft Zitat Ende wer diese
Zukunft will ja der kann bitte auch
weiter Rot-Grün wählen wer das
allerdings nicht will für den gibt es
Gott sei Dank eine Alternative vielen
Dank
der Bundestag in debattiert über die
Änderung des Atomgesetzes die drei noch
in Deutschland Netz befindlichen AKWs
sollen nicht am 31.12 sondern erst am 15
April abgeschaltet werden und die
nächste Redner in der Debatte ist Carina
Konrad von der FDP die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für diesen Bereich
wir ändern heute das Atomgesetz
das ist eine Frage der Vernunft diese
Entscheidung die ist unumgänglich
geworden und mit der
Laufzeitverlängerung der drei
Sicherungen und auch der drei
klimaneutralen Kraftwerke Isar 2 Emsland
und Neckarwestheim 2 wird die
Stromversorgung über den Winter
stabilisiert und darum geht es und die
emotionalen reden der Kollegen Harald
Ebner und Carsten Träger haben ja klar
gemacht dass der Weg hierher nicht
einfach war und er war auch nicht
selbstverständlich aber wir haben ihn
nicht zum Selbstzweck gemacht dass kein
Selbstzweck der Ampel dass diese
Laufzeitverlängerung heute beschlossen
wird bis in den April es geht darum die
Menschen sicher über den Winter zu
bringen und den Menschen die Angst zu
nehmen davor dass der stromausfallen
könnte dass man kalt sitzen könnte und
das not Elend und Verarmung und droht
und darum muss es gehen und
dafür zu sorgen dass die
Energieversorgung in Deutschland
gesichert ist der endet nicht hier am
heutigen Tag so viel ist auch klar
wir haben doch in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten alle erlebt wie sehr unsere
Gesellschaft strapaziert wird wie sehr
unsere Wirtschaft strapaziert wird wenn
Energiepreise so schnell so rasant
ansteigen
Putin versucht die Grundlage unseres
Wohlstands auszuhüllen und unsere
Industrie unsere Handwerksbetriebe
unsere Mittelständler die sind Grundlage
unseres Wohlstandes in unserem Land und
deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen diesen
Wohlstand auch zu erhalten und eine
sichere Energieversorgung gehört dazu
und wir haben gelernt dass
Energieversorgung nicht nur verfügbar
sein muss Energie muss auch bezahlbar
sein ansonsten wird die Wirtschaft
nachhaltig geschildert geschädigt
arbeitslosigkeiten drohen Abwanderungen
firmenverlagerungen das alles wollen wir
nicht und deshalb treffen wir heute auch
diese Entscheidung und wir haben auch
andere Entscheidungen getroffen auch das
wurde schon erwähnt und wir werden auch
noch andere Entscheidungen treffen
müssen denn wir sehen doch gerade in
einer Zeit in der die Wirtschaft nicht
mehr so stark wächst wie in der
Vergangenheit dass die
Illusion von die crows sich nicht
bestätigt sie bestätigt sich einfach
nicht wenn die Wirtschaft nicht mehr
wächst hat das nur Nachteile für alle
und wir haben uns wahnsinnig viel
vorgenommen als Ampel wir wollen die
Zukunft dieses Landes modernisieren und
gestalten und dann muss man auch bereit
sein Entscheidungen zu treffen damit das
möglich ist und die wirtschaftliche
Grundlage in unserem Land auch erhalten
bleibt deshalb müssen wir uns heute
schon Gedanken darüber machen wie wir
über den nächsten den über und den
Winter in zehn Jahren kommen darum muss
es jetzt gehen
und deshalb verlängern wir heute die
Laufzeit der drei AKWs um über diesen
Winter zu kommen deshalb treiben wir den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren und haben dafür
schon wegweisende Entschlüsse getroffen
deshalb treiben wir auch das Thema der
planungsbeschleunigung voran denn wir
haben uns zu bürokratisiert in diesem
Land und deshalb haben wir uns auch ein
belastungsmoratorium verordnet und
überprüfen das Belastungen für die
Wirtschaft nicht überproportional
ausgedehnt werden und deshalb müssen
die nächsten übernächst und den Winter
in zehn Jahren denn und wer heute den
Pioneer gelesen hat der sieht das gerade
auch mit Energie spekuliert wird 30
Tanklaster mit LNG Gas mit verflüssigem
Gas schippern vor den europäischen
Küsten und warten da dass die Preise
hier irgendwann steigen während unter
unseren Böden genau dieses Schiefergas
schlummert und auch heute
umweltfreundlich gefördert werden könnte
deshalb müssen wir uns Gedanken machen
darüber was geht und wie wir
weiterkommen und das ist der Weg den
diese Koalition geht es ist
natürlich gehen wir ihn wir gehen diesen
Weg und Sie werden sehen
[Musik]
sie hätten sie hätten sie hätten ja mal
für bei ihren Wählern für Zustimmung
werden können dann hätte es andere
Mehrheiten gegeben in diesem Haus
aber kein Stress-Test der Zukunft sein
darf und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
verantwortungsvolle Entscheidungen
miteinander treffen und das tun wir
heute vielen Dank
Carina konrad-still vertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP träumt
hier öffentlich von Fracking in
Deutschland vielleicht hat sie dafür die
falschen Koalitionspartner Ralf lenkert
jetzt von der Linken Sprecher für
Energie und Klimaschutz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Fraktion
DIE LINKE lehnt jeden Betrieb von
Atomkraftwerken ab
und ich sage Ihnen warum erstens
menschliches Versagen beim Betrieb ist
immer möglich siehe Tschernobyl zweitens
Naturkatastrophen sind mit bester
Technik nicht immer beherrschbar siehe
Fukushima drittens seit den
Terrorangriffen auf die Zwillingstürme
in New York kann niemand zu einem
Angriff auf einer Atomkraftwerk
ausschließen viertens seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffskrieges hat die Welt
Angst dass ein Supergau durch
Kriegshandlung passiert
fünftens
Materialalterung auch unvorhergesehene
Materialverschleiß unsachgemäße
Reparaturen aber auch fehlendes
Kühlwasser erhöhen die Risiken von
Atomkraftwerken siehe Frankreich wo nur
27 von eigentlich 56 Reaktoren Strom
liefern
weltweit gibt es nach wie vor kein
Endlager für Atome und niemand will
Atome vor seiner eigenen Haustür haben
siebentens kein Atomkraftwerk keine
Atomanlage ist versichert also liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sollt ihr
Eigentum bei einem Unfall verstrahlt
werden sie kriegen nichts ersetzt 8 ohne
Subvention ist Atomstrom mehr als vier
Mal so teuer wie heute
gewinnkraftanlagen
9 54 Prozent des angereicherten Urans
kommen aus Russland wie kann man da
die Herren von der Union AFD ernsthaft
russisches Uran als Alternative zu
russischen gasansehen
zehntens
Uranförderung belastet die Umwelt schwer
das weiß ich als Ostthüringer und die
Sanierung des Uranbergbaus kostete
Deutschland bisher mehr als 7 Milliarden
Euro und tausende Bergarbeiter bezahlten
die Förderung mit ihrer Gesundheit und
11 die deutschen Atomkraftwerke müssen
auch heute nur den technischen Stand von
1980 nachweisen das kann doch nicht wahr
sein
als Techniker in der Industrie musste
ich oft erleben dass nicht die beste
oder die sicherste Lösung umgesetzt
wurde sondern meistens die billigste
es bleibt dabei die Linke lehnt
Atomkraft aus diesen guten Gründen ab
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht wegen
des russischen Angriffskrieges nicht
wegen des Atomausstieges und nur wenig
bedingt durch die Gaspreise explodieren
die Strompreise falsche Marktregeln und
Spekulationen sind die Hauptursache für
den Strompreisanstieg
und um die Strompreise zu senken
brauchen wir keinen striktbetrieb von
Atomkraftwerken wir brauchen neue und
strenge Regeln im Stromsystem statt
Übertragungsnetzbetreibern Profite aus
Netzentgelten zu garantieren fordert DIE
LINKE die Übertragungsnetze zu
verstaatlichen
und wir fordern einen preiswertes
grundkontingent an Strom für Haushalte
Landwirtschaft und Handwerk
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger selbst bei
wenig Wind und keiner Sonne gibt es noch
genügend
Stromerzeugungskapazitäten in
Deutschland und unsere Versorgung zu
sichern das größte Risiko für unsere
Stromversorgung geht von Spekulation mit
Strom aus und von veralteten und
falschen Strom
im juni 2019 standen wir drei mal kurz
vor einem Blackout weil wegen
Bilanzfälschung
unser Stromsystem überlastet wurde und
die bilanzfläche und hatten nur einen
Sinn die Gewinnmargen der entsprechenden
Händler zu steigern und das ist das
eigentliche Risiko für unsere sichere
Stromversorgung
für die Linke ist Stromversorgung
daseinsversorge das Stromsystem muss da
einfach gesellschaftlich werden ohne
wenn und aber
und abschließend
ohne Atomkraftwerke gäbe es keine
Atombomben das sind Zwillinge auch aus
diesem Grund muss man Atomkraft ablehnen
atomstrom ist keine Lösung Atomkraft
schafft nur neue Probleme vielen Dank
so weit Ralf Linkert für die Bündnis
Grünen und Sie sehen es hier Steffi
Lemke sitzt hier auf der Regierungsbank
aber der nächste Redner ist nicht etwa
die Ministerin sondern Christian kühn da
steht auch schon auf von den Bündnis
Grünen ist der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Beispiel Lemke die in der
ersten Lesung am Mittwoch gesagt hat es
wäre absolut fahrlässig auf den Beitrag
der drei AKWs zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt zu
verzichten ja sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dieser Gesetzentwurf reiht sich
ein in die vielen Maßnahmen die diese
Bundesregierung ergriffen hat zu
Bewältigung der aktuellen Krise damit
Deutschland gut durch diesen Winter
kommt drei Gründe drei Gründe machen
diesen Gesetzentwurf notwendig erstens
der Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die
Ukraine und die dadurch ausgelöste
Energiekrise
zweitens die Krise der französischen
atomflotte dort steht die Hälfte der
Kraftwerke aktuell still aufgrund
massiver Sicherheitsprobleme der
Technologie der Atomkraft und drittens
das energiepolitische Fiasko aus 16
Jahren CDU geführter Bundesregierung
eine Melange eine Melange aus
Abhängigkeiten zu russischen Gas und
einer blockierten unverzögerten
Energiewende diese Bundesregierung diese
Bundesregierung handelt in diesen Tagen
zutiefst pragmatisch dieser
Gesetzentwurf und es wurde hier mehrfach
betont ist weder ein Herzensanliegen der
Grünen noch der SPD noch der FDP er ist
pragmatisch im Kern weil er eine
Entscheidung ist die auf den Ergebnissen
des Stresstestes beruht
und wir haben es uns wahrlich nicht
einfach gemacht mit dieser Entscheidung
aber eine einfache Entscheidung wäre
angesichts der Tragweite dieser
Verantwortung nicht gerecht geworden
meine Damen und Herren
wir halten am Atomausstieg fest mit
diesem Gesetz und gleichzeitig tun wir
das Notwendige um gut durch diesen
Winter zu kommen und die Netzstabilität
zu gewährleisten nicht mehr und nicht
weniger und ich habe ihn in der Union in
den letzten Tagen vor allem in dieser
Woche auch im Ausschuss hier im Plenum
sehr genau zugehört sie planen nichts
anderes als den Ausstieg aus dem
Atomausstieg sind sie doch mal so
ehrlich und sagen das hier auch sagen
das hier auch
sie haben 2011 den Ausstieg unter der
Bundeskanzler Frau Dr Merkel hier auf
den Weg gebracht und heute fordern Sie
den Betrieb der Atomkraftwerke bis zum
Sankt nimmerland-tag sie wollen neue
Brennelemente beschaffen sie wollen mehr
Atommüll in Deutschland produzieren und
damit das nukleare Risiko in diesem Land
erhöhen das ist die Wahrheit und das
muss heute auch gesagt werden
und sie wollen das nur aus einem Grund
weil sie bei der Atomkraft ideologisch
getrieben sind bis heute bis heute und
weil sie Herr Merz der Vergangenheit
angehören und nicht in die Zukunft
blicken und das zeigt auch ihr
Gesetzentwurf den sie heute mit
eingebracht haben ihr Gesetzentwurf
vermischt nämlich Betrieb und Aufsicht
bei der Frage wie sie die Atomkraft
weiter betreiben wollen und das ist
angesichts dieser fragweite dieser
Fragen angesichts der fragt der
nuklearen Sicherheit einer Opposition
hier im Deutschen Bundestag unwürdig
lassen Sie uns mit Hochdruck an der
Energiewende arbeiten weiter mit
Pragmatismus Handeln für zukünftige und
heutige Generation dankeschön
Christian kühn der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär von Steffi Lemke der
heute hier in der zweiten und dritten
Lesung gesprochen hat die Ministerin ist
zwar anwesend hat aber ja schon in der
ersten Lesung sich zu Wort gemeldet und
heute darauf verzichtet Julia Klöckner
jetzt für die CDU CSU sie ist sprechen
für Wirtschaft
guten Morgen sehr geehrter frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Staatssekretär kühn dass
sie so gegen ihren Koalitionspartner FDP
hier austeilen hätte ich jetzt auch
nicht gedacht
und es gibt schon einen Unterschied sie
haben eben gesagt sie hätten bei der
Anhörung zugehört es gibt schon
Unterschied zwischen Zuhören und
Verstehen und dann auch noch böser
Unterstellung und ich verstehe es ja
dass gerade die Grünen ein Problem haben
das ist ihnen auch schwerfällt diesen
Gesetzentwurf heute einzubringen und
auch ihre Haltung zur Kernkraft zu
überarbeiten und der Realität stückweise
anzupassen das kann ich verstehen aber
was ich nicht verstehen kann ist dass
sie ihre Schmerzen und Bindungen
abarbeiten an einer Opposition die mit
Fakten argumentiert und nicht mit
Ideologie so wie sie das hier machen ich
kann auch verstehen Liebe grünen wenn
man einen Jürgen Trittin in den Reinhard
der immer quer irgendwie im Stall steht
und sagt er lässt sich hier sein
Lebenswerk nicht in Zitat versauen da
sieht man natürlich dass die
kernkraftdebatte für sie zu einem
Selbstzweck geworden ist es geht hier
überhaupt nicht um die Frage wie können
wir diese Energiekrise die Menschen
Arbeitsplätze kostet die diesen Standort
in Deutschland nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig macht die die Menschen
abends mit sorgen ins Bett gehen lässt
steigende Energiepreise wie wir denen
jetzt her werden in einer Zeitenwende
das bedarf eigentlich auch eine neue
Justierung der politischen Sichtweisen
aber wenn jemand bei Ihnen sagt ich lass
mir mein politisches Lebenswerk nicht
zerstören oder Niedersachsen plakatiert
bei bei Atomkraft dann geht es ihnen
nicht mehr um die Sache nicht mehr um
die Menschen sondern um ihren
Gründungsmythos und das ist diesem Land
nicht gerecht das will ich Ihnen sehr
sehr deutlich sagen
und auch mit weiteren Märchen möchte ich
mal auflösen wir haben einen
Strombedarf jährlich etwa von 600
Terawattstunden in Deutschland die
Hälfte davon wird durch erneuerbare
Energien gedeckt und da kann ich sagen
Danke 16 Jahre Bundesregierung der CDU
und CSU und Herr kühn wenn sie dann mal
Richtung ja sie lachen jetzt ich weiß
dass Fakten ich weiß dass Fakten weh tun
und deshalb lachen sie ja heute auch
ihre große Ikone Greta Thunberg aus sie
haben ihr ja lange zugeklatscht aber
jetzt lachen Sie sie aus im übrigen
lachen sie auch die Experten ihre
gaspreiskommission aus sie lachen mit
ihren Lachen jetzt auch aus
Wirtschaftsweisen sie lachen mit ihrem
Lachen jetzt aus Studien der Uni
Erlangen die genau das besagen dass am
Ende der Energiepreis gesenkt werden
könnte und am Ende auch eine
Unabhängigkeit in Deutschland gesichert
werden könnte durch einen Remix es geht
doch nicht um Alles oder Nichts es geht
doch darum wie wir einen guten
Energie-Mix hinbekommen
Laufzeitverlängerung zwei Jahre länger
weil eines habe ich jetzt auch gelernt
im übrigen das war der Kollege Träger
der den Sekt schon kalt legt also nach
ihrer Lesart ist das ja so nach der
Ampel dass der Krieg sehr sicher am
15.4.2023 beendet sein wird dass sie das
Wissen ist hochinteressant und wenn sie
auch sagen dass an die Energiekrise
beendet sein wird jetzt ruft der reiner
in die Atomkraft wird beendet sein also
das ist ja schon eine hohe Form der
Dialektik der wir nicht mehr folgen
können Sie sagen auf der einen Seite
sie sagen auf der einen Seite die
Kernkraftnutzung ist so schlimm dass sie
ihren Kindern das nicht zumuten können
und es hätte nichts mit dem Krieg zu tun
Stichwort 15 vierter nächsten Jahres ja
dann müssen sie es ja wenn sie ihren
Kindern die Augen schauen wollen heute
doch beenden warum stimmen sie denn
heute überhaupt noch der Verlängerung zu
umtreibt entweder sind es Fakten oder
Ideologie oder ist das Machtwort des
Kanzlers der heute nicht hier sitzt bei
einer so wichtigen Frage
[Applaus]
ich mal haben sie dieses Wort genutzt
aber die Ergebnisse offene Prüfung im
übrigen die ist ja so nicht gelaufen und
transparent auch nicht weil ein grüner
Staatssekretär den Passus im Vermerk
streichen ließ dass die CO2-Reduktion
mit AKW Laufzeitverlängerung um 25 bis
30 Millionen Tonnen CO2-Reduktion
beinhalten würde das heißt ihnen geht es
doch gar nicht mehr um den Klimaschutz
ihnen geht es doch nur noch um
parteiprogrammatik Unternehmen sie in
Kauf dann nehmen Sie Doppelmoral in Kauf
und das muss ich sagen ist mehr als
fraglich denn sie endsolidarisieren sich
mit anderen Ländern in Europa Juniper
steigen wir ein uniper baut
Kernkraftwerke in Schweden andere Länder
in Europa müssen teure Preise zahlen
ärmere Länder auch nur Deutschland nutzt
die eigenen Möglichkeiten nicht und
deshalb sage ich sehr klar wir auch eine
Verantwortung anderen gegenüber wir
wollen gefrecktes Gas importieren selber
hier nicht fördern wir wollen
Kernenergie importieren selber hier
nicht produzieren das ist wegschieben
das ist wie moderner Kolonialismus und
das haben die Grünen zu verantworten und
deshalb bin ich sehr froh und damit
schließe ich dass unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender heute da ist im
Vergleich zu FDP die das nicht ertragen
kann und hier mit gratuliere ich ihm
sehr herzlich zum heutigen Geburtstag
die Bundestag debattiert über das
Änderung die Änderung des Atomgesetzes
die drei AKWs in Deutschland sollen
nicht am 31.12 abgeschaltet werden
sondern jetzt erst am 15 April kommenden
Jahres und die nächste Rednerin in der
Debatte kommt von der SPD Nina Scheer
sie ist die Sprecherin für Klimaschutz
und Energie
und ich höre gerade Friedrich Merz hat
heute Geburtstag der Fraktionschef der
CDU CSU und Julia Klöckner hatte ja
gerade hier im öffentlich gratuliert
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen da jetzt hier
gerade noch mal auf die Koalitionäre
Geschlossenheit angespielt wurde Frau
Klöckner ich möchte sie mal daran
erinnern was wir bei der letzten Runde
2010 hier erleben mussten und auch im
Vorfeld von 2010 als
Schwarz-Gelb damals
Laufzeitverlängerungen um alles in der
Welt beschließen wollte und ein ganzes
Jahr gebraucht hat um über Prognos
errechnen zu lassen dass dies denn nötig
sei ich betone sei damals hatten sie
auch intern einen großen Konflikt es gab
damals einen baden-württembergischen
Ministerpräsidenten Herrn matthus der
öffentlich den damaligen CDU
Umweltminister zum Rücktritt
aufgefordert hatte weil ihm das nicht
gereicht hat dass Herr Röttgen nur vier
Jahre Laufzeitverlängerung wollte man
hörte bei ihm sehr deutlich raus dass
auch diese vier Jahre ein Zugeständnis
waren dass er an sich nicht die
Selbstständigkeit von
Laufzeitverlängerung sah und immer und
immer wieder wurde betont aus ihren
dreien man brauche dies aus
versorgungssicherheitsgründen weil die
Menge nicht reichten dafür brauchte man
dann eben diese Studie ein Treppenwitz
war dann ja auch noch dass dann die
beteiligten Ministerien nebeneinander
standen diese prognosstudie in den in
den in die Kamera hielten Herr Röttgen
hatte ein offenkundig anderes Exemplar
kleiner Scherz beiseite aber ist das ist
das was 2010 zu Laufzeitverlängerung
geführt hatte und dann bekanntermaßen im
März 2011 Fukushima und nichts war
gewesen
man hat sich für den Ausstieg aus der
Rückabwicklung entschieden
und mit keiner Silbe mehr war irgendwie
erwähnenswert was denn zu dieser
komischen
rückwärtsgewandten Laufzeitverlängerung
geführt hatte denn es gab diese Lücke
nicht die sich herbeiräten
und jetzt sind wir sind wir zwölf Jahre
weiter wir haben massive Investitionen
der erneuerbare Energien getätigt leider
auf ihre Intervention hin sehr viel
langsamer als das mit dem Wunsch der SPD
gekommen wäre sehr viel langsamer wir
hatten im Jahr 2010 ungefähr 30
Milliarden Investitionen in erneuerbaren
Energien es war dann der absolute
Tiefpunkt im 2000 Jahr 2019 erreicht und
jetzt hatte sich dann etwas erholt aber
Sie müssen endlich mal eingestehen dass
das was sie mit der Atomenergie
öffentlich und auch in der
Erwartungshaltung verknüpfen die sie den
Menschen unterjubeln wollen dass das
bedeutet wir werden die Energiewende
verlangsamen das ist das eigentliche die
eigentliche Botschaft die sie mit ihrem
Gerede über Laufzeitverlängerungen die
ganze Zeit über wieder in die Welt
setzen es ist nachgewiesenermaßen so
dass in dem Moment wo Atomenergie im
Netz ist erneuerbare Energien verdrängt
werden und genau das war ja auch ein
Grund warum wir diese Frage mit dem
streckbetrieb auch sehr kritisch gesehen
haben denn es ist de facto so dass in
dem Moment wo Atome Energie im Netz ist
erneuerbare Energien kein Platz haben
wenn es eben zuletzt Engpässen kommt
wenn es zu Netz Engpässen kommt und das
ist leider immer wieder der Fall es ist
gerade wieder errechnet worden das in
Europa Laufzeitverlängerungen über das
bisher an europäischen Regelwerk
existiert Laufzeitverlängerung bedeuten
würden das 12% mehr erneuerbare Energien
aus dem Netz gedrängt würden das alles
ignorieren sie wenn sie weiterhin
weiterhin auf die Laufzeitverlängerung
setzen und natürlich ist es so dass
diese ganzen Gründe die ganzen Gründe
die auch schon immer gegen Atomenergie
gesprochen haben dass diese Gründe nach
wie vor Bestand haben auch das wird die
permanent von ihnen
unter den Teppich gekehrt es ist auch
schon von einigen meiner Vorredner
genannt worden alle hatten es im Gepäck
diese Argumente sind auch einfach nicht
aus der Welt zu schaffen es gibt in der
ganzen Welt kein einziges AKW und die
deutschen eingeschlossen was kriegs- und
krisensicher gebaut worden wären das ist
auch Deutschland der einfach verschieben
wird von ihnen Frau Dr cher gestatten
Sie einen nein
so nehmen sind es wird von ihnen einfach
verschwiegen dass natürlich die
Gesellschaft die Haftung übernimmt wenn
das nicht von dem Treibern übernommen
wird dieses ganze Modell von
Atomenergienutzung fußt darauf dass die
Gesellschaft die in das Ausfallrisiko
dieser Atomenergie Nutzung trägt und
zwar schon die ganze Zeit über wir haben
eine keine Betreiber wir haben eine
betreiberhaftung statt eine AKW bezogene
Haftung ab wir haben eine Haftungsgrenze
im Atomgesetz all dies sind
politische Entscheidungen gewesen um
überhaupt in eine Nutzung kommen zu
können die sich kostenseitig irgendwie
abbilden des wirtschaftlich irgendwie
abbilden lässt aber es ist eben auch an
der Zeit irgendwann zu sagen diese Dauer
Subventionierung die nur einem weiteren
Ausbau erneuerbare Energien im Wege
steht diese dauersubventionierung auch
versteckt muss endlich aufhören
und ich möchte auch einfach noch mal
einmal daran erinnern was wir in den
letzten Wochen hier entschieden haben
und wo wirklich der Fokus wenn es um
Energiesicherheit geht verstärkt drauf
gelenkt werden muss nämlich auf den
verstärkten auch bei erneuerbaren
Energien und alleine in den letzten
Wochen haben wir mit dem dritten
energiesicherungsgesetz mit der
Überarbeitung desselben Ende September
noch mal ein erneuerbaren Energien
Booster beschlossen alleine das was wir
dort an
ausnutzbaren Mengen schon bestehender
schon installierter Anlagen beschlossen
haben an Erleichterung für eine
Auslastung der schon bestehenden Anlagen
ist mehr als das was jetzt im
streckbetrieb ermöglicht wird das wird
auch leicht unter den Teppich gekehrt
meine Zeit ist leider beendet ich danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
hat das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
aus der afd-fraktion Rainer Kraft ja
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau Scheer
sie wiederholen hier einen erneut einen
Vorwurf der auch in der öffentlichen
Anhörung von vielen vermeintlichen
Experten geäußert worden ist dass Strom
der eine Strom den anderen irgendwie
blockieren würde also das sogenannte
kernkraftwerkstrom den Strom aus
sogenannten erneuerbaren Quellen
blockiert das ist erstens natürlich
nicht der Fall und zweitens ist wäre es
komplett umgesetzt ich denn das
erneuerbare Energien Gesetz kennt die
vorrangseinspeisung das heißt es ist per
Gesetz geregelt dass man immer eine
erzeugte Kilowattstunde aus sogenannten
erneuerbaren Energien ins Netz
eingespeist werden kann dass die
konventionellen heruntergefahren werden
müssen um Platz für die Aufnahme im Netz
dieser Kilowattstunde sogenannten
Erneuerbaren zu schaffen das heißt der
Effekt den Sie angesprochen haben und
den manche Experten in der öffentlichen
Anhörung haben vermuten wollen der ist
per Gesetz illegal den darf es gar nicht
geben außer unter der einzigen Ausnahme
dass wenn das Netz nämlich bereits mit
Energie aus sogenannter neu gesättigt
ist dass erst dann eine Kilowattstunde
aus sogenannten Erneuerbaren abgelehnt
werden kann vom
Netzbetreiber das heißt dass erneuerbare
gegengesetzt hat gesetzlich festgelegt
dass der von Ihnen beschrieben Effekt
dass das Netz mit sogenannten
kernkraftwerksturm voll wäre defakte
nicht existieren kann und darf das wäre
nämlich absolut ungesetzlich danke schön
Frau Dr schell möchten Sie antworten
[Applaus]
Herr Dr Graf sie müssten es eigentlich
besser wissen
sie unterstellen
mir Unwahrheit bzw faktenlosigkeit und
wollen das mit ihrerseitiger
faktenlosigkeit Belegen das ist mit
Verlaub etwas erbärmlich ja sie wissen
ganz genau sie wissen ganz genau dass in
Deutschland sehr viel Windstrom und auch
in Teilen Photovoltaik-Strom inzwischen
schon mit steigender Tendenz abgeriegelt
wird und das hat ein Grund weil die
Netzkapazität genau dann nicht ausreicht
wenn es aufgrund der fluktuierenden
Eigenschaft von erneuerbaren Energien
nicht ausreicht deswegen brauchen wir ja
auch ein Umbau des Stromsystems der auf
die Eigenschaften der erneuerbaren
Energien Rücksicht nehmen dieser Umbau
der ist natürlich ein zentrales Element
der Energiewende und daran wird ja auch
unter Hochdruck gearbeitet was Sie
ansprechen mit dem Vorrang erneuerbaren
Energien das führt ja auch dazu dass wir
eine Entschädigung eben diesen
abgeregelten Strom haben sonst würde der
sich ja gar nicht rechtfertigen diese
Entschädigung die steht für den Vorrang
aber aus nicht Sicherheitsgründen findet
diese Abriegelung statt und wenn Sie das
Verleugnen dann haben sie noch mal einen
neuen Level an Fakten Verleugnung
erreicht das tut mir sehr leid für sie
Herr Dopfer
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion Dr
Michael Kaufmann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin geschätzte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Abgeordnete der
vorliegende Entwurf des Atomgesetzes
greift viel zu kurz ist im Ergebnis aber
zu begrüßen interessant ist dass sie in
der Begründung auf genau jene Argumente
zurückgreifen die wir Ihnen in den
vergangenen Monaten immer wieder
vorgetragen haben
wir hätten wir hätten die nun anstehende
Entscheidung und damit ein gutes Stück
mehr Sicherheit für die Bürger also
schon viel früher haben können wenn sie
nicht auf beiden Ohren taub gewesen
werden nur weil die richtigen Argumente
von der AFD kommen
es es brauchte erst das Machtwort eines
Bundeskanzler um den zerstrittenen
Hühnerhaufen der Koalition wieder ein
Stück weit auf den Kurs der Vernunft zu
bringen
unabhängig von der geringen
Laufzeitverlängerung müssen wir aber die
Voraussetzungen schaffen damit unsere
Industrie die großen Chancen der
Kerntechnik nutzen kann deswegen haben
wir diesen Antrag gestellt
allerdings nach der Beratung im
Ausschuss frage ich Sie werte Kollegen
ob Sie unseren Antrag überhaupt gelesen
haben
quer durch alle Fraktionen wurde erklärt
dass in Deutschland keine Kernkraftwerke
mehr gebaut werden das aber geht am Kern
unseres Antrags völlig vorbei wir
fordern darin die öffentliche Förderung
der kernenergieforschung damit uns in
Deutschland das damit verbundene
wirtschaftliche Potenzial nicht verloren
geht
denn auch wenn sie es noch nicht bemerkt
haben im Hinblick auf die Kernenergie
ist Deutschland ein Geisterfahrer in der
Welt rund 90 Reaktoren befinden sich
weltweit in Planung weitere 60 werden
gerade gebaut und das ist zwar nicht in
nicht entfernen Regionen sondern in
unseren Nachbarländern in Nachbarländern
wie Polen den Niederlanden und
Frankreich
und diese Kernkraftwerke in den
Nachbarländern können uns vor Strom
sperren und den Blackout retten
wir setzen uns mit unserem Antrag dafür
ein dass dieses enorme wirtschaftliche
Potenzial der deutschen Industrie nicht
verloren geht die Ideologie geleitet der
Forschungspolitik gibt sich hingegen
alle Mühe die Entwicklung neuer und
bessere Reaktortechnik in Deutschland zu
unattraktiv wie möglich zu machen grüne
Politik ist der größte Standort Nachteil
für den Forschungsstandort Deutschland
und wenn Sie nun darauf verweisen dass
Forschung an der Kernenergie in
Deutschland ja nicht verboten sei dann
ist das mit Verlaub einfach lächerlich
und das wissen sie auch
indem Sie unseren Antrag ablehnen
schaden sie den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und betreiben indirekt
Wirtschaftsforschung für die
Wirtschaftsförderung für die USA
Russland oder China danke
Michael Kaufmann war das für die AFD der
nächste Redner in der Debatte kommt von
der FDP Lukas Köhler der ist der
zuständige stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzende
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ich glaube in
so einer Debatte die wir führen und die
wir zurecht ja auch sehr
emotional führen in diesem Hohen Haus
muss man sich verdeutlichen warum wir
überhaupt darüber sprechen warum es
nötig ist diese Debatte zu führen und
das ist nicht weil wir die große Debatte
die müssen wir auch hören aber was nicht
weil wir die große Debatte über die
Zukunft der Energieversorgung in
Deutschland führen sondern es ist ganz
klar weil Wladimir Putin einen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine führt
und gleichzeitig ein energiekrieg gegen
uns gegen Europa und es ist nötig es ist
nötig jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass all das
was wir tun können um über den Winter zu
kommen auch getan wird und das ist der
Grund warum diese Debatte heute hier
geführt wird
das ist der Grund für dieses Gesetz
kein der Diskussion kein ideologischer
Streit darüber ob wir jetzt
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen lassen oder
nicht sondern nur die Notwendigkeit über
diesen Winter zu kommen und das so
sicher wie es geht und das erlaubt
dieses Gesetz das hier vorgelegt wird
und ich bin froh darüber es ist ein
guter Tag für Deutschland weil wir dafür
sorgen dass Unternehmen
die Sicherheit haben über den Winter mit
ausreichend Energie zu kommen weil
Frankreich seine Atomkraftwerke nicht im
Griff hat weil wir zu wenig Gas haben
weil wir Probleme mit der Netzstabilität
haben und auch ja weil wir dafür sorgen
müssen dass die Preise im Strombereich
nicht nur durch einen strompreisdeckel
gesenkt werden sondern auch dadurch dass
wir alle Kapazitäten nutzen die wir zur
Verfügung haben
Herr Dr Köhler gestatten Sie eine Frage
oder Zwischenbemerkung aus der
afd-fraktion danke nein danke
die Diskussion die wir hier führen und
das ist das Wesentliche ist deine in
einer Situation entstanden in der Gas
nicht verstromt werden sollte unter
keinen Umständen weil wir müssen Gas
sparen wir müssen über diesen Winter
kommen indem wir so wenig Gas wie
möglich nutzen die Situation über das
kommende Jahr und so sieht es im Moment
aus ist aber eine andere wir haben LNG
Kapazitäten die wir ordentlich ausgebaut
haben wir haben eine neue Infrastruktur
wir importieren mehr Gas und ja die
Hoffnung besteht auch immer noch dass
Frankreich seine Stromversorgung wieder
in den Griff bekommt und deswegen sieht
das nächste Jahr anders aus und deswegen
ist es richtig jetzt über den 15.4 zu
sprechen deswegen ist es völlig korrekt
darüber nachzudenken wie kommen wir über
diesen Zeitraum über die kalte Zeit des
kommenden Jahres und da kein Gas zu
nutzen um Strompreise zu senken und für
Netzstabilität zu sorgen und es ist auch
richtig darüber zu sprechen wie wir 23
24 weitermachen aber da ist im Moment
die Antwort eindeutig Kohle und Gas und
ja auch das ist keine einfache Debatte
zum Glück ist aus klimapolitischer Sicht
der Schaden nicht so groß weil der
europäische Emissionshandel das ganze
regelt aber natürlich bedeutet diese
laufende Diskussion auch eine Debatte
darüber wie sieht die Stromversorgung in
Zukunft aus weil wir heute doch jetzt
schon wissen dass der alte Deal den wir
mal mit der Gesellschaft mit der
Wirtschaft geschlossen haben wir setzen
auf einen massiven Einstieg in
erneuerbare Energien und sorgen für eine
Grundversorgung in der deutschen
Energiewirtschaft durch Gas erst durch
Erdgas und dann durch Wasserstoff dass
dieser Deal so nicht funktionieren wird
denn das ist das Problem denn das
Problem ist doch dass wir günstiges
Pipeline Gas aus Russland nie wieder in
diesem Maß beziehen werden wie wir es
bisher getan haben und das ist auch
richtig so weil wir nicht abhängig sein
können aus anderen Quellen und wenn wir
dafür sorgen können dass der lng-preis
so niedrig ist dann funktioniert auch
die Diskussion aber
um die Energieversorgung in Zukunft
deutlich die Energieversorgung der
Zukunft Deutschlands sicherzustellen
werden wir jetzt dafür sorgen müssen
dass wir zum einen Debatte über den
Strommarkt führen eine Debatte darüber
wie sieht eigentlich eine Welt aus die
fast nur noch aus erneuerbaren Energien
besteht auch mit hohen wasserstoffkosten
und eine Debatte darüber wie kriegen wir
eigentlich ausreichend Gas um dahin zu
kommen und diese Debatte das ist das
eigentliche Wesentliche was wir jetzt
führen müssen die Debatte jetzt das zu
tun was nötig ist was richtig ist das
ist absolut korrekt
und ja der Not die Notwendigkeit
günstige Strompreise zu haben besteht
nicht nur für Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sondern sie besteht auch insbesondere
für all diejenigen die wie wir wollen
dass dieses Land klimaneutral wird denn
wir werden es nicht hinbekommen
Klimaneutralität durch die durch
dekarbonisiert durch die
Industrialisierung zu erzeugen sondern
wir werden dafür sorgen müssen dass
Wirtschaftswachstum und der die
Reduktion von CO2 miteinander
einhergehen und dazu brauchen wir
günstige Energie
die Herausforderung vor der wir aber
gerade stehen ist dass wir enorme
Investitionen brauchen wir brauchen aber
auch gleichzeitig enorme
planungsbeschleunigung ich glaube das
ist die Debatte die wir als nächstes in
diesem Bundestag führen müssen wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir in
Deutschland schneller werden mit
Infrastruktur mit energieausbau und ja
wir tun heute was nötig ist aber wir
werden morgen dafür sorgen dass wir das
tun was weiterhin richtig ist vielen
Dank
Lukas Köhler war das für die FDP
aus der afd-fraktion hat Herr bistron
frau Präsidentin vielen vielen Dank für
diese kurze Intervention lieber Herr
Kollege sie haben Ihren Vortrag mit
einer Falschbehauptung eröffnet also
bitte
wir führen hier diese Diskussion nicht
deswegen weil tausende Kilometer
entfernt von uns ein Krieg stattfindet
wir führen diese Diskussion weil die
Bundesregierung erstmal aus der
Atomkraft ausgestiegen ist weil 2011 und
da waren sie FDP mit an der Regierung
mit beteiligt weil hier ein Beschluss
gefasst wurde weil in Fukushima ein ein
Atomunfall war wo Menschen wo Menschen
ertrunken sind wegen einer Tsunamiwelle
da ist niemand ein Radioaktivität
gestorben aber hier wurde Panik geschürt
vor Atomkraft ja ich meine das Risiko
das in Deutschland eine Tsunamiwelle
drüber schwappt ist relativ gering nicht
aber sie haben trotzdem den Ausstieg
beschlossen sie haben beschlossen dass
der Strom subst erklärt wird durch Gas
wir haben dann auf Gaskraftwerke
umgestiegen harten günstiger
Lieferverträge von Russland langfristige
Verträge diese kippen sie wiederum das
in alles politische Entscheidungen das
sind alles Falsche politische
Entscheidungen und ich verstehe schon
dass sie sich da aus der Verantwortung
rausziehen wollen als FDP aber die
Wahrheit bleibt einfach eine andere der
Krieg ist nicht daran Schuld schuld
daran sind ihre falschen politischen
Entscheidungen
Herr Dr Köhler möchten Sie antworten
[Applaus]
Liebe Kollege ich habe noch versucht die
Frage zu entdecken aber
die zweifelhafte Verhältnis der AFD zu
Russland ist ja bekannt und dass sie
nicht akzeptieren können dass das
Problem vor der wir gerade stehen
deswegen entsteht weil eine politische
Entscheidung getroffen wurde und zwar
nicht hier im Haus sondern von Wladimir
Putin dieses Land anzugreifen der ist
dazu geführt hat dass Wladimir Putin
versucht diese Energiekrise dafür zu
nutzen selber zu erzeugen und dafür zu
nutzen dass dieses Land vor die Hunde
gehen und dass wir uns mit aller Kraft
der demokratischen Parteien in diesem
Haus dagegen stemmen das ist mir klar
dass sie das nicht akzeptieren können
aber es ist traurig es ist traurig dass
ihre Fraktion darauf hofft dass dieser
Winter dazu führen wird das ist uns
schlecht geht weil sie sich politisch
davon erhoffen dass es ihnen gut geht
was ist das denn für eine Absurdität
sich hier hinzustellen und zu sagen dass
dieser Krieg nicht dafür verantwortlich
ist ist eine Absurdität der Geschichte
und erklärt sich leider nur dass sie
völlig verloren sind in ihrer
politischen Ausrichtung und dass sie
ganz dringen ihr Verhältnis zu Wladimir
Putin und zu Russland überdenken sollten
wenn sie das hier als Argument vorführen
es tut mir leid
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Bernhard Hermann
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
während 86 nach Tschernobyl die kleine
Tochter von Harald Ebner keinen Frühling
erlebte ließ man uns als 20-jährige
Grundwehrdienstleistende durch die
brandenburgischen wälderrobben
wir sammelten Pilze
die Atomlobbyisten aller politischen
Systeme waren sich schon immer
erschreckend einig verharmlost
verschwiegen und verantwortlich
aber mit dieser Erfahrung in die
Gegenwart
am Mittwoch ging der größte schwedische
Atomreaktor und planmäßig vom Netz heute
vor einer Woche hat die französische
Atomaufsichtsbehörde das Hochfahren des
Reaktors kattenorm 1 untersagt defekte
Schweißnähte gefährdeten die nukleare
Sicherheit nur mal zwei von unzähligen
Beispielen diesen Jahres die eins ganz
klar zeigen Atomkraftwerke sind keine
zuverlässige stabile Energiequelle
in Frankreich sieht man die Folgen
atomfreundlich Energiepolitik mehr als
die Hälfte der Kraftwerksleistung fehlt
seit Monaten am Netz die Strompreise
sind dort deutlich höher als hier in
Deutschland auch zu Stunde übrigens bei
uns drücken viel Wind und Sonnenstrom
den Großhandelspreis na klar dass das
einigen weh tut und nicht gefällt
trotzdem aber
oder eben deshalb halten einige
Ideologen weiter an der mehr
zuverlässiger günstiger Atome mit AG
fest und verkaufen Sie dann das
klimafreundliche Brücke zu einer
Energiewelt mit 100% erneuerbaren dabei
gehört die Atomkraft ebenso wie Fracking
zur alten Welt konventioneller Energie
ist eben keine Brücke in die neue Welt
sie ist ein Brückenpfeiler auf Sumpf
gebaut
der Atomkraftwerke sind unflexibel
können die Produktion nicht an Verbrauch
und volatile Erzeugung aus Sonne und
Wind anpassen sie verstopfen die Netze
zwingend dazu erneuerbare abzuschalten
für uns grüner ist klar der Atomausstieg
ist nötig und daran rütteln wir nicht
neue Brennstäbe mit neuem Atommüll gibt
es mit uns definitiv nicht
aber
der Energiekrise begegnen wir mit allen
sinnvoll verfügbaren Maßnahmen gerade in
diesem Winter besteht die Gefahr dass es
über begrenzte Zeit zu kritischen
netzsituationen kommen könnte die
geordnetes abschalten erfordern könnten
geringer übrigens als anderswo auch in
Westeuropa der Stress das hat gezeigt
dass die süddeutschen LKWs einen sehr
begrenzten Beitrag leisten können die
Situation zu entspannen in Abwägung
zwischen nuklearer Sicherheit und
Energieversorgungssicherheit halte ich
daher deren streckbetrieb für fachlich
vertretbar das trifft für das AKW
Emsland nicht zu in Norddeutschland gibt
es genügend andere Kraftwerkskapazität
der dort fachlich für mich nicht
nachvollziehbare streckbetrieb ist ein
sehr schwer hinnehmbarer politischer
Kompromiss das wird mich nach
gewissenhafter Abwägung jedoch nicht
davon abhalten den Regierungsantrag
zuzustimmen
denn das wichtigste was dieser eben auch
enthält und explizit vom Kanzler
bestätigt wurde es wird keinen neuen
Brennelemente geben und am 15 April 23
werden die verbleibenden AKWs endgültig
abgeschaltet und unsverzüglich
rückgebaut
Herr Bundeskanzler vor allem auch sie
stehen hier im Wort vielen Dank
nächste nächster Redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Andreas Lenz
Andreas Lenze Sprecher für Energie und
Nachhaltigkeit der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen es ist schon eine
besondere Episode der ampelpolitik die
wir im Kontext der Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke erleben zunächst wurden
vom Ministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz sowie vom Umweltministerium
Prüfungen nach dem Motto durchgeführt
weil nicht sein kann was nicht sein darf
verrücken Sie nicht unser ideologisches
Weltbild unsere Meinung steht bereits
fest vor der Prüfung des Sachverhalts
wurden wieder besseres Wissens
Stellungnahmen vorformuliert ohne die
Fachebene einzubeziehen ohne den Rat und
die Expertise der Kraftwerksbetreiber zu
berücksichtigen ohne die Studienlage zu
berücksichtigen ohne auf den Rat von
Fachbeamten zu hören wurde mehr als ein
Vermerk erstellt indem dann auch den 100
stand ein weiter Betrieb sein nicht sei
nicht zu empfehlen inhaltliche Punkte
zum sehr wohlmöglichen sicheren
Weiterbetrieb CO2 zu co2-
zu kais-dämpfungseffekten wurden
schlichtweg unterschlagen und
ausgeblendet und das das ist im höchsten
Maße unseriös meine Damen und Herren
tricksen und tricksen und Täuschen
leugnen und Lügen unterschlagen und das
Unterdrücken von Kritik es drängt sich
der Eindruck auf das in den Ministerien
so gearbeitet wurde das Ganze das Ganze
garniert mit andauernden Aussagen wie
beispielsweise wir haben wir hätten
keinen Stromproblem oder es würden durch
einen Weiterbetrieb nur marginale Mengen
Gas eingespart werden eine
ergebnisoffene Prüfung
zuzusagen und sie dann nur vorzugaukeln
das ist schon ganz schön dreist meine
Damen und Herren und
und
Herr Habeck ist eben doch nicht der
andere der ehrlichere Politiker als den
er sich ja gerne darstellt lügen haben
kurze Laufzeiten so kann man den
Sachverhalt gut zusammenfassen meine
Damen und Herren
und dann
und dann kam eine bestellte
richtlinienentscheidung aus dem
Kanzleramt um die Basis der Parteien
sowohl der grünen als auch der FDP quasi
zu besänftigen das ist eine riesige
Mogelpackung meine Damen und Herren
schaut man sich an was der Weiterbetrieb
ist zum 15 April beinhaltet dann ist
beim Kraftwerk Emsland aber auch bei den
anderen ein massiver Abfall der Leistung
und damit der produzierten Strommenge
verbunden das bedeutet schreckbetrieb in
Emsland ist es so dass von jetzt 1,3 die
die Leistung auf im April dann nur noch
0,6g die Leistung entsprechend die
Leistung reduziert werden wird das
Problem ist dass eben keine neuen
Brennstäbe bestellt werden diese sind
aber notwendig denn es wird auch
2023/24 einen Winter geben und auch da
wird Strom gebraucht werden sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren und
und deshalb müssen wir jetzt bestmöglich
da darauf vorbereitet sein und
entsprechend auch die Brennstäbe
bestellt werden und ich muss ganz offen
sagen ich bin ich bin gespannt wann die
FDP eigentlich merkt dass sie wirklich
die allerletzten sind die sich hier
durchgesetzt haben sie lassen sich doch
hier gerade von den Grünen aus
ideologischen Gründen verhaften sie
können heute gerne ihrem eigenen
Vorschlag zustimmen wenn Sie unseren
Vorschlag zustimmen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir
brauchen nach wie vor jede
Kilowattstunde die Lage ist nach wie vor
Ernst mehr Strom mehr Strom aus
Kernkraft führt zu weniger verschwunden
Gas zu weniger CO2-Emissionen zu
sinkenden Preisen und leistet an den
Beitrag zur Versorgungssicherheit und
zur Netzstabilität auch über den 15
April hinaus herzlichen Dank
Andreas Lenz war das für die CDU CSU
der nächste Redner war mal in der
afd-fraktion ist dort ausgetreten jetzt
also fraktionslos Robert fahle hat hier
das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die Ampel will
drei Kernkraftwerke jetzt drei Monate
weiterlaufen lassen sie haben
offensichtlich Angst vor dem ersten
Protest der Bürger sobald der erste
Blackout Auftritt die Grünen
transformationsideologen bestehen auf
der endgültigen Abschaltung weil sie
Argumenten in keiner Weise mehr
zugänglich sind
die Nationalistin Ulrike Herrmann hat es
mit verblüffender Ehrlichkeit auf den
Punkt gebracht ich zitiere man muss sich
klar machen dass Klimaschutz den totalen
Umbau bedeutet da bleibt kein Stein auf
dem anderen dann ist klar dass es das
grüne Wachstum nicht geben wird sondern
was wir hier haben werden ist grüne
schrumpfen wir müssen raus aus dem
Kapitalismus Zitat Ende ihnen geht es
nicht um den Klimawandel und das Klima
sondern um den totalen Umbau weg von
einer freiheitlichen sozialen
Marktwirtschaft hier zu einer CO2
gesteuerten
Misswirtschaft und schrumpfwirtschaft
und Mangelwirtschaft
alle Verfahren der Energieerzeugung die
eine industrielle Produktion ermöglichen
sind in Deutschland von ihnen diskutiert
diskreditiert worden übrigens bleiben
nur noch Windkraftanlagen und
Solarpaneele die für die industrielle
Produktion nicht taugen wenn es ihnen um
CO2 ginge dann wäre das
co2-abscheideverfahren nicht verboten
dann werden die e-fuels zugelassen dann
würden Kernkraftwerke dauerhaft
weiterlaufen müssen in der ganzen Welt
der Fall ist sie wollen mit der
Brechstange zurück ins vorindustrielle
Zeitalter ins Mittelalter kein
motorisierten Individualverkehr keine
Einfamilienhäuser keine Flugreisen kein
Fleisch Verzehr kein Silvesterfeuerwerk
Verbote statt Freiheit sehr geehrter
Herr Habeck sie haben uns bezüglich der
Energieversorgung gelogen und betrogen
tre du sie endlich ab
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Jakob blankenburg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben in
dieser Woche sehr intensiv über das Für
und Wieder der Verlängerung der
AKW-Laufzeiten gesprochen und zwar nicht
nur hier im Plenum sondern auch im
Petitionsausschuss im Rahmen einer
öffentlichen Anhörung mit zahlreichen
Expertinnen und Experten aus der
Wissenschaft und im Umweltausschuss und
nach diesen vielfältigen Beratungen
stehen wir heute hier um zu entscheiden
wie lange die drei noch am Netz
befindlichen Atomkraftwerke Emsland Isa
2 und Neckarwestheim 2 weiterbetrieben
werden entweder wie von der
Unionsfraktion vorgeschlagen mindestens
zwei Jahre länger also bis Ende 2024 mit
einem Hintertürchen für weitere
Laufzeitverlängerung und wenn sie
ehrlich werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union dann würden Sie
sagen dass es das ist was sie eigentlich
wollen dieses Hintertürchen oder wie von
der Regierungskoalition vorgeschlagen
für dreieinhalb Monate bis zum 15 April
des nächsten Jahres
meine Meinung dazu ist klar wir schaffen
mit dem akw-streckbetrieb über den wir
heute reden bis zum 15 April ein
weiteres Sicherheitsnetz für die
Energieversorgung auch wenn wir
eigentlich davon ausgehen dass wir es
nicht brauchen werden aber mit dieser
Entscheidung zum temporären
Weiterbetrieb der übernimmt die
Regierungskoalition Verantwortung in
schwierigen Zeiten in denen Energie
sorgen Bürgerinnen und Bürger genauso
umtreiben wie die zahlreichen kleinen
und großen Betriebe in diesem Land
und zu Recht haben wir uns diese
Entscheidung nicht leicht gemacht denn
es ging um eine sehr grundsätzliche
Abwägung zwischen den Aspekten
Sicherheit Gesundheitsschutz
Versorgungssicherheit und Bezahlbarkeit
von Energie die Aufgabe einer
verantwortungsvollen Regierung ist es
all diese Aspekte miteinander in
Einklang zu bringen und das ist uns
gelungen wir halten am Atomausstieg fest
wie wir es auch 2021 im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben wir
kaufen keine neuen Brennstäbe wir nutzen
vorhandene Ressourcen zu
Energieerzeugung komplett aus konkret
holen wir noch das letzte bisschen
Energie aus den in den AKW eingesetzten
Brennstäben heraus
und und wir behalten uns mit dem
zeitlich sehr begrenzten
akw-streckbetrieb die Sicherheitsrisiken
und Entsorgungsfragen der Nutzung der
Atomkraft im Blick wir gehen als
Koalition eben nicht nach dem Prinzip wo
gehobelt wird da fallen Späne vor wie
das während der Expertin eine hörung von
einem Sachverständigen der Union als
gangbarer Weg betrachtet wurde für uns
ist ganz klar die Nutzung der Atomkraft
ist und bleibt riskant
als als Regierungskoalition der
übernehmen wir außerdem Verantwortung
beim Thema Energiepreise der Strompreis
dämpfende Effekt des akw-streckbetriebs
ist das ist das Lieblingsargument der
Unionsfraktion für ihren Gesetzentwurf
aber es ist fraglich ob der AKW
Weiterbetrieb überhaupt zu spürbaren
Effekten beim Strompreis führt das haben
hat auch die öffentliche Anhörung am
Mittwoch noch mal intensiv ergeben
vielleicht hätten da einige Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aus der Unionsfraktion noch
mal besser aufpassen sollen
die oder anwesend sein auch ein guter
Tipp die Aussagen der Wissenschaft über
die absenkende Wirkung des AKW
Weiterbetriebs auf den Strompreis die
unterscheiden sich stark und werden vor
dem Hintergrund unterschiedliche
Annahmen getroffen aber was sie vereint
sie sind nicht groß genug um wirkliche
Entlastung bei Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sowie Unternehmen beim Strompreis zu
sorgen das Preisargument ist also ein
vorgeschobenes Argument und das zu
fordern was sie auch schon vor dem
abscheulichen Angriff Kriegs Russland
auf die Ukraine und der daraufhin
folgenden Energiekrise gefordert haben
den mehrjährigen Weiterbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke was wir mit Blick auf
bezahlbare Energie wirklich brauchen
sind grundlegende Veränderungen auf der
systemischen Ebene und genau diese
systemischen Ebene die gehen wir jetzt
an und bei Bürgerinnen und Bürgern sowie
Unternehmen auch für kurzfristige
Entlastung zu sorgen da bringen wir
schon jetzt konkrete Instrumente auf den
Weg die Strom- und gaspreisbremsen
werden kommen und es wird gezielte
entlastungszahlungen geben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist geht
uns als Regierungskoalition also darum
dass wir genug Energie das genug Energie
zur Verfügung steht und auch darum dass
sie dass sie bezahlbar bleibt beides
werden wir auch nach dem 15 April
sicherstellen wenn das letzte
Atomkraftwerk abgeschaltet ist das ist
das was es braucht nicht dass ein
weiterköcheln der Diskussion über den
Atomausstieg in den Winter in den
Wintermonaten Entscheidung wieder
aufzuschnüren bringt und bringt uns
energiepolitisch nicht weiter nur der
beschleunigte Ausbau Erneuerbaren
erneuerbare Energien hilft uns
nachhaltig bei der Überwindung der
Energiekrise frau Präsidentin letzter
Satz liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass
Sie uns hier und heute nach gründlicher
Abwägung eine Entscheidung über eine
befristeten streckbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke treffen und uns dann
wieder den anderen dringenden
dringenderen Fragen zu wenden vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
Blankenburg war das für die SPD der
vorletzte Redner hier ist Fabian
gramling von der
cdu/csu und danach wird es dann drei
namentliche Abstimmung hier im Plenum
geben aber zunächst fahren wir an
gramling Herr Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in diesen Tagen
findet die Weltklimakonferenz in Ägypten
statt 190 Nationen reden über den
Klimaschutz und wir haben im Deutschen
Bundestag bisher uns diesem Thema noch
nicht gewidmet ganz im Gegenteil heute
letzter Tagesordnungspunkt werden wir
darüber sprechen ich persönlich finde
das beschämend und wenn wir
und wenn wir über das Klima reden wenn
wir über Klimaschutz reden dann müssen
wir natürlich hier erneuerbaren Energien
ausbauen und da gibt es diverse Studien
die besagen dass wir ab 2027 einen
Großteil der Strom des Strombedarfs
überneubacher Energie decken können aber
wie so häufig in Studien des der Fall
ist muss man natürlich diese Studien
auch ganz genau lesen und genau
hinschauen und wenn wir diese Studien
genau anschaut dann sieht man die
Annahme dass der Erneuerbaren
energienbereich die
ausbaugeschwindigkeit vor vierfacht
werden muss liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vervierfacht werden muss und
wenn wir jetzt mal wenn man jetzt mal
die aktuelle Situation anschaut wie ist
es denn bei den erneuerbaren Energien
schreien sie weniger ist besser für den
Blutdruck wenn man mal schaut wie die
aktuelle Situation bei den in der
Branche der neubahnenergien ausschaut
dann sieht man dass man das eine
Schockstarre vorherrscht warum auf der
einen Seite der Krieg auf der einen
Seite aber auch ihre Diskussion über die
gewinnabgabe über die Gewinnabschöpfung
Planungssicherheit hier für die
Unternehmen fehlanzeige
von da frage ich mich ob es
verantwortbar ist in einer Zeit wo wir
nicht wissen wie schnell kriegen wir
denn die erneuerbaren Energien ausgebaut
in einer Zeit wo wir nicht wissen wie
viel Gas haben wir denn im nächsten Jahr
oder im übernächsten Jahr sie haben also
selbst erkannt dass man die
Kohlekraftwerke hochfahren muss aber ich
frage mich ob es vernünftig ist in einer
solchen Zeit in einer Energiekrise gegen
den Expertenrat nicht nur gegen den
Willen der CDU und bisschen der FDP
sondern gegen den Willen und gegen die
Empfehlung des expertenrades die letzten
drei Kernkraftwerke Mitte April 23
abzuschalten ich halte das nicht
verantwortbar
und wir reden wir reden auf der einen
Seite über Versorgungssicherheit wir
reden aber auch über das Klima Stichwort
Klimakonferenz in Ägypten und wenn man
da mal schaut was die Beamten im
Bundesumweltministerium
niedergeschrieben haben bzw nicht wieder
geschrieben niedergeschrieben als würde
wieder rausgestrichen aber es ist ja
relativ ist ja die Frage die sich jetzt
deuten möchten aber wenn wenn Beamte im
Umwelt Bundesumweltministeriums sagen
dass ein Weiterbetrieb der drei
verbleibt verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke ab
2024 zu einer Reduzierung der CO2
treibhauskarte führen können von bis zu
30 Millionen Tonnen dann frage ich mich
und dann stelle ich mir die Frage ob sie
heute bewusst im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes die Probleme von morgen weiter
befeuern dass sie morgen sich darüber
beklagen können liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der ampelfraktion Herr gramling
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Zwischenbemerkung aus der Fraktion der
Grünen ich würde gerne weitermachen
auch deshalb weil wir im März viel
gehört haben was alles nicht geht im
März hieß es im Winter helfen keine
Kernkraftwerke im März ist die
Laufzeitverlängerung ist nicht möglich
weil es gibt Sicherheitsbedenken im
Mercedes die der Weiterbetrieb sein
nicht möglich weil die Mitarbeiter nicht
vorhanden sind heute stellen wir fest
dass es möglich ist und es ist auch
heute möglich Trennelemente zu bestellen
und diese predelemente im Frühsommer 23
einzusetzen es liegt an ihrem Willen
lieber ampelregierung und verstehen Sie
mich da nicht falsch aber wenn Sie heute
eine Beschaffung ablehnen da müsst ihr
auch morgen die volle Verantwortung für
das nicht tun fragen
und wir haben und wir haben viel über
Ergebnis auf eine Prüfung gesprochen wir
haben viel auch über den prüfvermehr
gesprochen der er dann auch wieder
irgendwie zusammengestrichen wurde aber
über den eigenen schildbücher
bürgerstreicht haben wir noch nicht
gesprochen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie möchten heute beschließen
dass die Kernkraftwerke Mitte April 23
abgeschaltet werden auf der anderen
Seite hat aber das
Wirtschaftsministerium geplant Ende
April zwei Wochen später den Stresstest
für den Winter 23 24 es vorzulegen ich
halte das als unseriös ich halte das als
für unwillkürlich und ich halte das als
unanständig wir fordern sie auf legen
Sie den Stress-Test früher vor und
folgen Sie unserem Antrag und lassen Sie
die Kernkraftwerke länger laufen vielen
Dank
so und die letzte Rednerin hier in
dieser Debatte zum Änderung des
Atomgesetzes ist
Lina Seidel von der SPD sie ist im
Ausschuss für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz
Blick zurückwerfen einen Blick zurück in
das Jahr 2000 bzw 2002 wo die damalige
rot-grüne Landesregierung den Ausstieg
aus der Atomkraft in Deutschland
beschlossen hat dann ein Blick zurück in
das Jahr 2010 und diese Entscheidung
durch die damalige schwarz-gelbe
Bundesregierung zurückgenommen wurde und
dann ein Jahr später
2011 wieder zurückgeworden um wurde der
Ausstieg aus den Ausstieg aus dem
Ausstieg und wenn ich Ihren Antrag jetzt
folgenden hätten wir noch ein viertes
aus dem Ausstieg müsste man hinten
dranhängen
2011 haben sie diese Entscheidung
getroffen hat dieses Haus diese
Entscheidung getroffen in einem breiten
Konsens gesellschaftlich und politisch
als Reaktion auf die Nuklearkatastrophe
in Fukushima es gab die klare politische
Einigung und der klare politische und
gesellschaftliche Konsens die Atomkraft
hat in Deutschland keine Zukunft
und dabei bleibt es wir halten auch mit
dieser Entscheidung heute am
Atomausstieg fest es werden keine neuen
Brennelemente angekauft und es werden
gleichzeitig umfangreiche Maßnahmen zum
Energiesparen durchgesetzt und gut durch
diesen Winter zu kommen damit zeigen wir
einmal mehr wir übernehmen Verantwortung
in keinen ganz einfachen Zeichen wir
zeigen wir sichern uns ab für eine
Extremsituation wenn vorhandene
stromressourcen gegebenenfalls nicht
überall im Land aus erreichen aber wir
legen auch ein finales Ausstiegsdatum
fest nämlich den 15 April 2023
und es gibt und es gibt auch gute Gründe
warum wir das tun und warum wir nicht
eine Verlängerung über dieses Datum
hinaus anstreben erstens der Beitrag der
Atomkraft zur Energiesicherheit und zur
Bezahlbarkeit von Energie ist gering RKW
können kein Gas ersetzen sondern sie er
Strom und mein Kollege Blankenburg hat
schon gesagt der Effekt auf den
Strompreis ist zumindest mal fraglich
sicher ist dass es so gering ist dass es
nicht wirklich zu Entlastung von
Verbrauchern Verbrauchern kommt diese
Entlastung setzen wir in der Koalition
mit den Strom und gaspreisbremsen besser
durch zweitens
der eine Verlängerung würde den Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren weiter behindern
erneuerbare sind in Kombination mit
Speichertechnologien viel flexibler als
gernkraftwerke sie sind unsere Zukunft
wir sollten hier keine Ressourcen
rausziehen sondern wir sollten auf den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren setzen drittens
Atomkraft kommt mit hohen Risiken die
Entscheidung von Schwarz-Gelb damals
2011 war ja eine Reaktion auf eine
solche Nuklearkatastrophe in Fukushima
und wir können brauchen nur in die
Ukraine gerade gucken da sehen wir die
besorgniserregendes Situation von
Kernkraftwerken und viertens
Atomkraft ist das Gegenteil von
Nachhaltigkeit und
Generationengerechtigkeit wir
produzieren seit Jahrzehnten atomaren
Müll von dem wir heute nicht wissen wo
wir ihn entsorgen das ist eine Hypothek
für alle nachkommenden Generationen und
Atom benötigt unglaubliche Mengen von
Wasser angesichts des Klimawandels keine
gute Idee wer sich das anguckt da guckt
mal im Sommer nach Frankreich wo viele
Kernkraftwerke auch wegen der
Trockenheit abgeschaltet werden mussten
wir treffen heute also eine kluge
Entscheidung in einer schwierigen
Situation und und das ist der Blick nach
vorne wir müssen wegkommen von dieser
Diskussion wir müssen hinkommen zum
schnellen Ausbau der Erneuerbaren zur
schnellen Entwicklung und Nutzung von
intelligenten Speichertechnologien das
ist die Zukunft der Strom- und der
Energieversorgung in Deutschland vielen
Dank
so das war's die Debatte und nun hören
wir mal der Bundestagspräsidentin zu
Bärbel Bass es gibt gleich drei Namibia
zunächst einige Hinweise zum
abstimmungsverlauf zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt werden wir drei
namentliche Abstimmung durchführen die
jeweils für 10 Minuten eröffnet werden
wir beginnen mit der namentlichen
Abstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung es folgt dann die
namentliche Abstimmung über den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der cdu/csu
und schließlich die namentliche
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der AFD nach
der Schließung der ersten beiden
namentlichen Abstimmung unterbreche ich
jeweils kurz die Sitzung um die
Abstimmung inhaltlich voneinander zu
trennen und um die Urnen auszutauschen
die Beratung zur Tagesordnungspunkt 33
beginnt erst nach Schließung der dritten
namentlichen Abstimmung
wir kommen nun zu den Abstimmungen
Abstimmung über den von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes dazu liegen mir mehrere
persönliche Erklärungen nach § 31
unserer Geschäftsordnung vor der
Ausschuss für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf den Drucksachen
4.357 und
4423 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
4217 anzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen die
dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um
das Handzeichen
das sind die Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und die FDP wer stimmt
dagegen dass die Fraktion der Linken
einige Abgeordnete aus der Fraktion der
Grünen Bündnis 90 grüne die
cdu/csu-fraktion
dagegen
Enthaltung
die afd-fraktion Enthaltung
der Gesetzesentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen
wir kommen jetzt zur dritten Beratung
und Schlussabstimmung die Fraktion DIE
LINKE hat namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme in der
westlobby ca 10 Minuten Zeit ich
erinnere daran dass nach der
namentlichen Abstimmung die Sitzung kurz
unterbrochen wird ich bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer die
Plätze einzunehmen ich bekomme das
Signal das ist erfolgt
dann eröffne ich hiermit die erste
namentliche Schlussabstimmung
ja meine Damen und Herren jetzt gilt es
hier für die
Bundestagsabgeordneten zunächst einmal
über den Gesetzentwurf der
ampelregierung abzustimmen der Entwurf
eines 19 Gesetzes zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes soll nach dem Willen der
Ampel auch der letzte sein nämlich dort
ist festgeschrieben dass die drei
Atomkraftwerke die noch am Netz sich
befinden weiterlaufen sollen über den
31.12 dieses Jahres hinaus aber am 15
April sollen sie abgestellt werden
spätestens dann und danach soll es keine
Atomenergie in Deutschland mehr geben
ganz wichtig auch es sollen keine neuen
Brennstäbe beschafft werden das ist der
Kompromiss den quasi der Bundeskanzler
für die streitende Ampel im Oktober
festgeschrieben hatte sie erinnern sich
es gab das Machtwort des Bundeskanzlers
der genau diese Lösung empfohlen hat
nachdem die Bündnisgrünen den
Atomausstieg bis zum 31.12 eigentlich an
dem festhalten wollten dann aber
aufgrund auch des Krieges in der Ukraine
und der Problematiken was die
Energieversorgung angeht gesagt haben
okay die zwei süddeutschen Kraftwerke
die können als Einsatzreserve sozusagen
noch am Netz bleiben und dann abberufen
werden wenn wir sie brauchen und die FDP
hat damals argumentiert dass es zu wenig
wir brauchen auch für den Winter 23 24
eine Versorgung mit ordentlichem Strom
auch schon wegen der Preise und deswegen
brauchen wir längere Laufzeiten der AKWs
der Bundeskanzler hat dann von seiner
sogenannten
richtlinienkompetenzgebrauch gemacht und
diese diesen Kompromiss über den jetzt
hier abgestimmt wird eben quasi
aufgrund seiner Richtlinienkompetenz
dieser Ampel mitgegeben das war eine
große Belastungsprobe im Oktober für die
Ampel aber Olaf Scholz hat sie auf diese
Art und Weise
geregelt und die
736 Abgeordneten ich sagte es gerade sie
sehen sich hier an den Urnen im Flur
schön dass wir das auch sehen können
müssen jetzt ihre Stimmkarten einstecken
sind damit aber noch lange nicht fertig
denn danach kommt noch ein Gesetzentwurf
der
cdu/csu die eine längere Laufzeit der
AKWs wünschen und dann eine
Beschlussempfehlung zu einem Antrag der
AFD der im Großen und Ganzen ebenfalls
längere Laufzeiten und eine Erforschung
der Atomkraft auch in Zukunft in
Deutschland sich zum Ziel gesetzt hat
und zehn Minuten wird jetzt über diesen
ersten Antrag der Ampel abgestimmt nein
über den ersten Gesetzentwurf der Ampel
abgestimmt muss ich sagen dann werden
die Urnen getauscht wir haben es gehört
deswegen eine ganz kurze zusatzpause und
danach dann 10 Minuten Abstimmung über
den unionsentwurf dann wenn die Ohren
wieder getauscht und dann 10 Minuten
Abstimmung über
den Antrag der AFD so ist das Prozedere
alles ein bisschen kompliziert muss aber
alles seine Ordnung haben wir haben mal
gerechnet übrigens
416 Abgeordnete hätte die Ampel hier im
Deutschen Bundestag die Mehrheit 369
dürfte nicht in Gefahr sein wenn gleich
sie eben ja auch Bärbel Bars gehört
haben bei der zweiten namentlichen
Abstimmung zu dem Gesetz der Ampel gab
es Gegenstimmen der bündnisgrün das war
vorher auch angekündigt worden es gibt
doch den ein oder anderen grünen der
diesen dieses Machtwort des
Bundeskanzlers diesen Kompromiss sage
ich mal nicht mitgehen will und deswegen
wird es sicherlich nicht alle Stimmen
aus der Ampel für den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung hier gleich geben
ich habe hier vor dieser Debatte mit
Harald Ebner dem Vorsitzenden des
Ausschusses für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz gesprochen und mit
Stefan Bilger dem zuständigen
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der CDU CSU und dieses Interview wollen
wir noch einmal zeigen ich habe Harald
Ebner mit dem Machtwort des
Bundeskanzlers konfrontiert und dieses
war die Ausgangslage und nun also das
Interview von heute morgen noch einmal
wie sauer sind die Grünen eigentlich
noch auf den Bundeskanzler
wir sind gar nicht sauer aber lassen Sie
mich eins sagen weil sie sagen die
Grünen wollten zum 31.12 Schluss mit der
Atomenergie machen das waren einstimmige
Beschluss des Deutschen Bundestages im
Juni 2011 also die ganze Republik der
gesamte Bundestages war einstimmig es
waren
gesellschaftspolitischer Konsens ein
gesellschaftlicher Konsens zum 31.12
diesen Jahres aus der Atomenergie
auszusteigen und das ist bis jetzt
geltende Rechtslage richtig aber dann
kam der Krieg und die Probleme die damit
einhergehen und deswegen noch mal die
Frage damit was gleich mal festmachen
werden die Grünen denn heute dieser
Verlängerung der Laufzeit bis zum April
zustimmen es wird für uns ja nicht
einfach wir hatten eine Notfallreserve
für zwei Kraftwerke im Süden das wäre
auch sachgerecht gewesen was die
energietechnischen Fragen angeht
vorgesehen
wir tun uns schwer mit jedem Tag den die
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen wir können
aber gut damit leben dass keine neuen
Brennstäbe das ist für uns die rote
Linie dass keine neuen Brennstäbe
beschafft werden dass kein neuer
Atommüll anfällt weil die Endlagersuche
ist bis heute ungelöst insoweit tragen
wir die heute zur Abstimmung stehende
Lösung den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung mit
man merkt den Grünen fällt das erkennbar
schwer logisches ist ja eine Art
gründungsideena gegen Atomkraft zu sein
die Union sieht das ein bisschen anders
sie sagt wir haben eine Notlage wir
wollen die AKWs länger laufen lassen
nämlich bis zum 31.12 24 warum dieser
Termin und ihnen ist schon klar das
haben sie auch reingeschrieben dass sie
neue Brennstäbe brauchen und da sagen
viele Experten also wenn man neue
Brennstäbe einsetzt dann müssen die auch
mindestens drei vier Jahre besser
brennen warum also 24 Ende
wir sind in einer Energiekrise und ich
glaube allen ist bewusst dass wir da
wirklich vom großen Problem stehen
deswegen hat die Ampel sich auch
durchgerungen zu diesem Minimalkonsens
zumindest die Laufzeiten bis April zu
verlängern um über diesen Winter zu
kommen aber das wird nicht reichen denn
der kommende Winter darauf folgende
Winter 23 24 wird voraussichtlich noch
härter werden also dieser Minimalkonsens
in der Regierung reicht nicht aus in der
Tat der große Unterschied zwischen den
beiden Gesetzentwürfen die heute zu
Abstimmung stehen wir plädieren dafür
neue Brennstäbe zu beschaffen die
Laufzeiten mindestens bis Ende 24 zu
verlängern wir haben in unserem
Gesetzentwurf auch eine Evaluierung
vorgesehen das sind dann im Sommer 24
überprüft ob ein nochmalige Verlängerung
nötig ist wir stehen zum Atomausstieg
aber ich glaube in der jetzigen
Situation es ist einfach nicht
verantwortungsbewusst aus politischen
Gründen diese Option wegzugeben wo wir
nicht wissen ob wir wirklich
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten
können wo die Strompreise viel zu hoch
sind wo es auch um eine Frage der
europäischen Solidarität und nicht
zuletzt auch um den Klimaschutz geht
dann viel Kohle zu verfeuern statt die
Kernkraftwerke am Netz zu Lasten das
macht ja wirklich nicht so richtig Sinn
hey immer ich zitiere mal die
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke von den
Grünen aus der ersten Lesung am Mittwoch
sie hat gesagt es wäre absolut
fahrlässig auf diesen Beitrag zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt zu verzichten diese
drei AKWs das ist an Erkenntnis die hat
sie nicht das ganze Jahr über gehabt und
diese Erkenntnis ist ja auch eine die
die anderen oppositionsverteilen teilen
und sagen deswegen brauchen wir das
wahrscheinlich auch noch im kommenden
Winter wo ist da der Unterschied zum
Winter 23 und da wird ja einiges
ausgeblendet also zum einen die
Erkenntnis ist ja dem zweiten
verschärften Stresstest durch die
Netzbetreiber geschuldet die aber gesagt
hat im Grundsatz können diese drei
Atomkraftwerke kaum und maximal einen
marginalen Beitrag zur Netzstabilität
leisten und schon gar nicht zum
gaseinsparen und schon gar nicht was die
Preise angeht desto der erste Punkt der
der Unterschied zur Union ist dass wir
sagen
wir wollen dass die Kraftwerke zur
Verfügung stehen in dem Fall indem man
sie braucht es hat sich jetzt erledigt
durch den durch den Beschluss der
ansteht sie laufen durch bis zum 15.4
also ein begrenzter Weiterbetrieb bis
längstens 15.04 das ist ein wesentlicher
Unterschied und der der dritte Punkt
wenn ich die Krokodilstränen höre was
den Klimaschutz angeht bei der Union
dann frage ich mich einfach täglich
warum haben wir in den letzten 16
unionsgeführten Jahren in dieser
Republik nicht mehr Klimaschutz gesehen
nicht mehr ausbaut erneuerbaren Energien
und das genau ist das was wir jetzt in
diesem Jahr mit wirklich einer bislang
nie dagewesenen Geschwindigkeit auf den
Weg gebracht haben und das wird es auch
sein was uns dann in den und über den
nächsten Winter tragen wird sind sie
auch vorstellen wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass jetzt die Gasspeicher zu 100%
gefüllt sind
letzten Herbst waren die leer wir haben
ein Gesetz geschaffen das dafür sorgt
dass das passiert und wir haben es
geschafft obwohl die russischen
Gaslieferungen komplett ausgesetzt sind
und damit sorgen wir vor und damit
schaffen wir uns auch eine Sicherheit
für die kommenden Jahre weil da der
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren dann auch massiv
voran kommen wird das Argument kommt ja
immer wieder in den letzten 16 Jahren
ist zu wenig passiert man bräuchte
eigentlich mehr erneuerbare Energie die
hat man jetzt aber nicht und
interessanterweise hat man auch im
ersten halben Jahr unter der Ampel nicht
mehr Zubau an Windrädern zum Beispiel
als unter der großen Koalition woran
liegt das
ich muss zunächst mal Herrn Ebner
widersprechen also die Bundesregierung
will ja nicht mit mehr erneuerbaren
Energien durch diesen und den nächsten
Winter kommen sondern vor allem mit dem
wieder Anfeuern von Kohlekraftwerken und
das hat mit Klimaschutz dann wirklich
nichts zu tun man kann darüber streiten
was wir bisher in Klimaschutz erreicht
haben in Deutschland muss allerdings
auch darauf hinweisen 1990 hat man sich
ein Ziel gesetzt den CO2-Ausstoß und 40%
zu reduzieren bis 2020 das haben wir
erreicht also wir haben durchaus einiges
geschafft als Industrienation wo wir
auch darauf achten müssen dass wir die
Versorgung mit Energie sicherstellen so
dass es für die Verbraucher zu
bezahlbaren Preis möglich ist und das
auch die Arbeitsplätze erhalten werden
ich komme aus Baden-Württemberg wir eben
auch hier im Bundestag wird immer den
Bayern und der CSU vorgehalten die
hätten nichts erreicht beim Ausbau der
Windkraft also in Baden-Württemberg in
elf Jahren grüne Umweltminister sieht es
auch nicht anders aus klar wir brauchen
eine Kraftanstrengung sind aber auch
wieder bei Themen wo die Grünen
gefördert sind weil bisher war es halt
oft so dass der Naturschutz oder andere
Fragen
schnelleren Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien entgegenstanden also da müssen
dann auch die Grünen über den Schatten
springen da gibt's Bewegung das begrüße
ich auch sehr und wir sind absolut dazu
bereit nochmal einen richtigen Schub zu
geben beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien denn das ist ja unser
gemeinsames Ziel dass wir irgendwann zu
100% erneuerbaren kommen und die
fossilen Energien nicht benötigen und
auch die Kernkraft nicht mehr benötigen
aber damals noch einen Weg zu gehen aber
ist das nicht auch ein Grund warum die
Bundesregierung und auch die Grünen
Ministerinnen und Minister in der
Bundesregierung jetzt sagen okay für die
sind ja für diesen Winter brauchen wir
noch Atomkraft auch weil man die
Erkenntnis gewonnen hat dass eben die
Kohlekraftwerke gar nicht so schnell ans
Netz gehen können
genau das ist ja der Punkt darauf habe
ich vorhin hingewiesen der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren wurde ja behindert in den
letzten 16 Jahren das ist aber jetzt in
diesem Winter links aber aus dieser
Erkenntnis heraus wir können ja nicht
Windräder einfach herzaubern weil sie
schon gesagt haben in den ersten sechs
Monaten ist da noch nichts passiert ich
meine sie haben einen Planungsvorlauf in
sechs Monaten bauen sie auch kein
Windrad so also das heißt wir haben
jetzt Hürden aus dem Weg geräumt die die
Union aufgebaut hat es waren wahnsinnig
viele Schikanen im Übrigen auch für die
binnen für die Windkraft an Land gerade
in Baden-Württemberg da kamen gar keine
Anträge mehr obwohl wir in
Baden-Württemberg das von der Union
damals geschaffene verhinderungsrecht
aufgehoben haben damit diese diese
windkraftplanung schneller vorankommen
kann so also vor diesem Hintergrund
haben wir gesagt wir müssen alles
beschleunigen was geht
die lng-terminals die geb werden auch
noch mal auf Kohle und Öl zurückgreifen
aber lassen Sie mich das auch sagen wir
müssen auch einsparen dazu gibt es auch
Incentives Anreize für die für die
Industrie und Vereinbarungen und ist
gerade heute morgen hat die
Bundesnetzagentur auch noch mal
mitgeteilt oder was gestern um also wie
viel eingespart wurde die Industrie ich
glaube zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent und
die Privathaushalte sogar fast 50
Prozent das muss man sich mal vorstellen
das ist eine unglaubliche Leistung die
wir da alle zusammen die die Menschen in
diesem Land alle zusammen hinbekommen
haben und in der Summe in der Summe sind
wir überzeugt dass wir mit diesen
Maßnahmen gut über den Winter kommen
dass wir mit diesen Maßnahmen auch nicht
unsere Klimaziele gefährden denn
gleichzeitig haben wir heute in der
ersten Lesung auch die Vereinbarung den
Kohleausstieg der Union um acht Jahre
vorzuziehen wir steigen acht Jahre
zumindest im Rheinischen Revier schon
mal acht Jahre vorher aus der Kohle aus
und damit bleiben bleiben Millionen
Tonnen Kohle im Boden und werden nicht
verfeuert das ist ein echter Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz Klimaziele nicht verfehlen
das ist ein gutes Stichwort denn gestern
gerade hat die deutsche Delegation viel
Kritik von internationalen Professoren
und Wissenschaftlern gekriegt für die
Tatsache dass hier
lng-terminals aufgebaut werden bei der
internationalen Konferenz
Umweltkonferenz das ist ja in der Tat
auch nicht so einfach mit diesen g
Terminals die sind jetzt erstaunlich
schnell aus dem Boden gestampft worden
das erste wird wohl schon kommende oder
ich glaube kommende Woche eingeweiht
dass er schneller als man in Deutschland
die erwarten konnte aber ganz ohne sind
diese lngs ja auch nicht es gibt großes
Unverständnis in Europa und in der Welt
über die aktuelle Energie- und
Klimapolitik dieser Bundesregierung also
Beamte aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium aus dem
Bundesumweltministerium haben in Entwurf
das prüfvermerks von März zur Frage der
Weiternutzung der Atomkraft
angeschrieben wenn die Atomkraftwerke
weiter betrieben werden im
Leistungsbetrieb dann bedeutet das 25
bis 30 Millionen Tonnen CO2-Einsparung
pro Jahr das ist eine riesen Summe das
die Hälfte dessen was die Landwirtschaft
pro Jahr in CO2-Emissionen
verantwortlich ist und das gibt man
einfach weg macht stattdessen mehr Kohle
baut lng-terminals wir unterstützen den
Bau der lng-terminalsweise aus unserer
Sicht nötig ist und unsere
Energieversorgung zu sichern wir müssen
jetzt eben alles tun damit die
Verbraucher die Sicherheit haben dass
auch die Unternehmen die Sicherheit
haben aber solche Entscheidungen
Kernkraft abzuschalten oder auch andere
Fragen die wir zurzeit diskutieren die
Bundesregierung wollte die Förderung für
kleine Wasserkraftwerke streichen sie
wollte die Möglichkeiten beim Biogas
Deckeln das sind alles seltsame
Entscheidungen wenn es eigentlich heißt
es kommt auf jede Kilowattstunde an und
wir wollen auch den Klimaschutz ernst
nehmen Herr Müller vielen Dank dass Sie
daran es klingelt nämlich und Sie müssen
dringend rein weil sie einer der ersten
Redner sind Herr Ebner da sind wir
gespannt wenn du nur sagen Klimaschutz
ist sehr wichtig wir müssen gleichzeitig
aber die nukleare Sicherheit genauso ins
Kalkül ziehen und wenn wir uns etwas
einkaufen eine Kilowattstunde wir können
die uns nicht um jeden Preis einkaufen
nämlich nicht um den Preis eines
erhöhten nuklearen Risikos und den
vermeiden wir diesen Preis vermeiden wir
ja meine Damen und Herren das war das
Interview heute Morgen vor der Debatte
Harald Ebner hat es dann noch
rechtzeitig in den Plenarsaal geschafft
er war der erste Redner und haben wir
auch nicht so oft Steffen Bilder war
tatsächlich dann der zweite Redner in
der Debatte um die Änderung des
Atomgesetzes seit ungefähr zwei Minuten
läuft jetzt hier die zweite namentliche
Abstimmung sie sehen wie die
Abgeordneten da sich drängen im Flur wo
nämlich die Urnen stehen seit Corona und
die zweite namentliche Abstimmung da
geht es um den Gesetzentwurf der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion die ja ein
weiterlaufen der AKWs bis Dezember 24
fordern und auch den Neukauf von
Brennstäben und
die erste Abstimmung über den
Gesetzentwurf der Ampel eben der
Ausstieg aus der Atomkraft dann
spätestens zum 15 April kommenden Jahres
dieser Ausstieg ist jetzt bereits
abgestimmt und wird dann ausgezählt da
werden wir sicherlich das gleich wieder
bekommen das Ergebnis
Uhren gefischen wir das
jetzt
namentliche Abstimmung wir ich krieg
gleich das Signal wenn wir das
ausgetauscht haben und dann machen wir
die Abstimmung noch mal von vorne so
dass auch alle wissen dass wir über den
Gesetzentwurf in zweiter Beratung der
cdu/csu abstimmen
ja Bärbel Basis seit einem guten Jahr
bundestagspräsidentinnen macht das hier
wirklich sehr ordentlich sie hat ja auch
brillante Vorgänger gehabt die hier die
Vorlagen gegeben haben aber die spd-frau
ohne Fehl und Tadel heute ist ihr
offensichtlich vorhin ein kleiner Fehler
unterlaufen und in interessant ich habe
auch kurz aufgezuckt als sie nämlich die
Abstimmung eben aufgerufen hat weil da
hat sie was von ausschussempfehlung etc
erzählt dabei geht es jetzt in der
Abstimmung die gerade wieder gestoppt
wurde aufgrund dieses Fehlers um den
Gesetzentwurf der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und da das
hier alles mit Recht und Ordnung zugehen
muss und die junge Dame vielleicht sehen
sie hinter ihr hat völlig zu Recht
darauf hingewiesen dass die
Bundestagspräsidentin hier eben quasi
ein Fehler hatte im Aufruf zur zweiten
namentlichen Abstimmung deswegen muss
das ganze jetzt wiederholt werden es
geht wohlgemerkt nicht um die Abstimmung
die bereits findet ist zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes das ist der ampelantrag der
hier höchstwahrscheinlich auch die
Mehrheit nachher finden wird sondern es
geht um die zweite Abstimmung die seit
drei Minuten hier gelaufen ist jetzt
unterbrochen wurde zum Gesetzentwurf der
cdu/csu alles ein bisschen kompliziert
aber das muss ja hier mit Recht und
Ordnung zugehen jetzt wird noch mal
telefoniert und noch mal bestätigt ja
das wie gesagt die Dame die wir da sehen
neben Bärbel Bars im Moment sehen wir
sie nicht das ist sozusagen die Juristin
die Notarin die das hier noch einmal
zurechtweist und sagt wir müssen es so
und so machen da sehen wir jetzt das
Bild ja und das zu kann passieren war
eigentlich aber auch nicht weiter nötig
denn die Abgeordneten wussten sehr wohl
dass es jetzt um den Gesetzentwurf der
cdu/csu geht aber namentlich öffentlich
hat es die Bundestagspräsident
offensichtlich etwas verwirrend oder
sogar falsch angekündigt deswegen also
jetzt ein Stopp so jetzt sehen wir mal
hier die Abgeordneten
700 wo habe ich sie 36 Abgeordnete haben
wir im Deutschen im Parlament und
ja es wäre nicht alle da sein aber viele
die auch gewusst haben dass natürlich
hier heute morgen am Freitagmorgen diese
Abstimmung auf sie zukommt der ein oder
andere schaut da mal schnell in die
Lektüre es dauert dann doch ein bisschen
länger als alle Beteiligten hier vor Ort
gedacht haben aber da kann man mal mit
dem ein oder anderen reden Friedrich
Merz den wir vorhin schon mal gehört
haben hat heute Geburtstag wird 67 Jahre
alt und wurde hier von Julia Klöckner
sogar beglückwünscht und das wollen wir
Ihnen jetzt auch noch mal zeigen denn
hier tut sich im Moment ja nicht so
wahnsinnig viel und deswegen wollen wir
noch mal in die Debatte von heute morgen
reinschauen mit zunächst den
parlamentarischen
Staatssekretär im Umweltministerium
Christian kühn der heute hier das Wort
ergreifen durfte obwohl Steffi Lemke der
Ministerin auch im Raum ist dass es auch
nicht so häufig der Fall aber Steffi
Lemke hatte am Mittwoch in der ersten
Lesung gesprochen und hat heute ihren
Staatssekretär vorgelassen und erwidern
tut daraufhin die von mir schon eben
erwähnt Julia Klöckner sie Sprecherin
für Wirtschaft der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
dieser
Gesetze vielen Maßnahmen die diese
Bundesregierung ergriffen hat zur
Bewältigung der aktuellen Krise damit
Deutschland gut durch diesen Winter
kommt drei Gründe drei Gründe machen
diesen Gesetzentwurf notwendig erstens
der Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die
Ukraine und die dadurch ausgelöste
Energiekrise zweitens die Krise der
französischen atomflotte dort steht die
Hälfte der Kraftwerke aktuell still
aufgrund massiver Sicherheitsprobleme
der Technologie der Atomkraft und
drittens das energiepolitische Fiasko
aus 16 Jahren CDU geführter
Bundesregierung eine Melange eine
Melange aus Abhängigkeiten zu russischen
Gas und einer blockierten unverzögerten
Energiewende
diese Bundesregierung diese
Bundesregierung handelt in diesen Tagen
zutiefst pragmatisch dieser
Gesetzentwurf und es wurde hier mehrfach
betont ist weder ein Herzensanliegen der
Grünen noch der SPD noch der FDP er ist
pragmatisch im Kern weil er eine
Entscheidung ist die auf den Ergebnissen
des Stresstestes beruht und wir haben es
uns wahrlich nicht einfach gemacht mit
dieser Entscheidung aber eine einfache
Entscheidung wäre angesichts der
Tragweite dieser Verantwortung nicht
gerecht geworden meine Damen und Herren
wir halten am Atomausstieg fest mit
diesem Gesetz und gleichzeitig tun wir
das Notwendige um gut durch diesen
Winter zu kommen und die Netzstabilität
zu gewährleisten nicht mehr und nicht
weniger und ich habe ihn in der Union in
den letzten Tagen vor allem in dieser
Woche auch im Ausschuss hier im Plenum
sehr genau zugehört sie planen nichts
anderes als den Ausstieg aus dem
Atomausstieg sind sie doch mal so
ehrlich und sagen das hier auch sagen
das hier auch
sie haben 2011 den Ausstieg unter der
Bundeskanzler Frau Dr Merkel hier auf
den Weg gebracht und heute fordern Sie
den Betrieb der Atomkraftwerke bis zum
Sankt nimmerland-tag sie wollen neue
Brennelemente beschaffen sie wollen mehr
Atommüll in Deutschland produzieren und
damit das nukleare Risiko in diesem Land
erhöhen das ist die Wahrheit und das
muss heute auch gesagt werden
und sie wollen das nur aus einem Grund
weil sie bei der Atomkraft ideologisch
getrieben sind bis heute bis heute und
weil sie Herr Merz der Vergangenheit
angehören und nicht in die Zukunft
blicken und das zeigt auch ihr
Gesetzentwurf den sie heute mit
eingebracht haben ihr Gesetzentwurf
vermischt nämlich Betrieb und Aufsicht
bei der Frage wie sie die Atomkraft
weiter betreiben wollen und das ist
angesichts dieser fragweite dieser
Fragen angesichts der fragt der
nuklearen Sicherheit einer Opposition
hier im Deutschen Bundestag unwürdig
lassen Sie uns mit Hochdruck an der
Energiewende arbeiten weiter mit
Pragmatismus Handeln für zukünftige und
heutige Generationen dankeschön
[Applaus]
dass sie so gegen ihren
Koalitionspartner FDP hier austeilen
hätte ich jetzt auch nicht gedacht
und es gibt schon einen Unterschied sie
haben eben gesagt sie hätten bei der
Anhörung zugehört es gibt schon
Unterschied zwischen Zuhören und
Verstehen und dann auch noch böser
Unterstellung und ich verstehe es ja
dass gerade die Grünen ein Problem haben
das ist ihnen auch schwerfällt diesen
Gesetzentwurf heute einzubringen und
auch ihre Haltung zur Kernkraft zu
überarbeiten und der Realität stückweise
anzupassen das kann ich verstehen aber
was ich nicht verstehen kann ist dass
sie ihre Schmerzen und Windungen
abarbeiten an einer Opposition die mit
Fakten argumentiert und nicht mit
Ideologie so wie sie das hier machen ich
kann auch verstehen Liebe grünen wenn
man einen Jürgen Trittin in den Reinhard
der immer quer irgendwie im Stall steht
und sagt er lässt sich hier sein
Lebenswerk nicht in Zitat versauen da
sieht man natürlich dass die
kernkraftdebatte für sie zu einem
Selbstzweck geworden ist es geht hier
überhaupt nicht um die Frage wie können
wir diese Energiekrise die Menschen
Arbeitsplätze kostet die diesen Standort
in Deutschland nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig macht die die Menschen
abends mit sorgen ins Bett gehen lässt
steigende Energiepreise wie wir denen
jetzt her werden in einer Zeitenwende
das bedarf eigentlich auch eine neue
Justierung der politischen Sichtweisen
aber wenn jemand bei Ihnen sagt ich lass
mir mein politisches Lebenswerk nicht
zerstören oder in Niedersachsen
plakatiert bei bei Atomkraft dann geht
es ihnen nicht mehr um die Sache nicht
mehr um die Menschen sondern um ihren
Gründungsmythos und das ist diesem Land
nicht gerecht das will ich Ihnen sehr
sehr deutlich sagen
und auch mit weiteren Märchen möchte ich
mal auflösen wir haben einen
Strombedarf jährlich etwa von 600
Terawattstunden in Deutschland die
Hälfte davon wird durch erneuerbare
Energien gedeckt und da kann ich sagen
Danke 16 Jahre Bundesregierung der CDU
und CSU und Herr kühn wenn sie dann mal
Richtung ja sie lachen jetzt ich weiß
das Fakten ich weiß dass Fakten weh tun
und deshalb lachen sie ja heute auch
ihre große Ikone Greta Thunberg aus sie
haben ihr ja lange zugeklatscht aber
jetzt lachen Sie sie aus im übrigen
lachen sie auch die Experten ihre
gaspreiskommission aus sie lachen mit
ihren Lachen jetzt auch aus
Wirtschaftsweisen sie lachen mit ihrem
Lachen jetzt aus Studien der Uni
Erlangen die genau das besagen dass am
Ende der Energiepreis gesenkt werden
könnte und am Ende auch eine
Unabhängigkeit in Deutschland gesichert
werden könnte durch einen Remix es geht
doch nicht um Alles oder Nichts es geht
doch darum wie wir einen guten
Energie-Mix hinbekommen
Laufzeitverlängerung zwei Jahre länger
weil eines habe ich jetzt auch gelernt
im übrigen das war der Kollege Träger
der den Sekt schon kalt legt also nach
ihrer Lesart ist das ja so nach der
Ampel dass der Krieg sehr sicher am
15.4.2023 beendet sein wird dass sie das
Wissen ist hochinteressant und wenn sie
auch sagen dass dann die Energiekrise
beendet sein wird jetzt ruft der Rhein
nein die Atomkraft wird beendet sein
also das ist ja schon eine hohe Form der
Dialektik der wir nicht mehr folgen
können Sie sagen auf der einen Seite
sie sagen auf der einen Seite die
Kernkraftnutzung ist so schlimm dass sie
ihren Kindern das nicht zumuten können
und es hätte nichts mit dem Krieg zu tun
Stichwort
15.04 nächsten Jahres ja dann müssten
sie es ja wenn sie ihren Kindern in die
Augen schauen wollen heute doch beenden
warum stimmen sie denn heute überhaupt
noch der Verlängerung zu
also da müssen sie doch mal ehrlich
bleiben was sie denn hier umtreibt
entweder sind es Fakten oder Ideologie
oder ist das Machtwort des Kanzlers der
heute nicht hier sitzt bei einer so
wichtigen Frage
und es geht hier um die Standortfragen
ich will aber auch eines noch betonen
dabei
ihr Lieblingswort im Koalitionsvertrag
ist ja Transparenz fast 30 Mal haben sie
dieses Wort genutzt aber die Ergebnisse
offene Prüfung im übrigen die ist ja so
nicht gelaufen und transparent auch
nicht weil ein grüner Staatssekretär den
Passus im Vermerk streichen ließ dass
die CO2-Reduktion mit AKW
Laufzeitverlängerung um 25 bis 30
Millionen Tonnen CO2-Reduktion
beinhalten würde das heißt ihnen geht es
doch gar nicht mehr um den Klimaschutz
ihnen geht es doch nur noch um
parteiprogrammatik Unternehmen sie in
Kauf dann nehmen Sie Doppelmoral in Kauf
und das muss ich sagen ist mehr als
fraglich denn sie endsolidarisieren sich
mit anderen Ländern in Europa Juniper
steigen wir ein uniper baut
Kernkraftwerke in Schweden andere Länder
in Europa müssen teure Preise zahlen
ärmere Länder auch nur Deutschland nutzt
die eigenen Möglichkeiten nicht und
deshalb sage ich sehr klar wir haben
auch eine Verantwortung schon gegenüber
wir wollen frag effectice Gas
importieren selber hier nicht fördern
wir wollen Kernenergie importieren
selber hier nicht produzieren das ist
wegschieben das ist wie moderner
Kolonialismus und das haben die Grünen
zu verantworten und deshalb bin ich sehr
froh und damit schließe ich dass unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender heute da ist im
Vergleich zu FDP die das nicht ertragen
kann und hiermit gratuliere ich ihm sehr
herzlich zum heutigen Geburtstag
[Applaus]
ja meine Damen und Herren also das war
Julia Klöckner heute Morgen und hat hier
nochmal ihren Fraktionsvorsitzenden
Friedrich Merz zum 67 Geburtstag
gratuliert auch etwas ungewöhnlich vom
Rednerpult
Bärbel Baas hat das dann auch noch
nachgeholt und mittlerweile sitzt hier
als Parlamentspräsident Wolfgang Kubicki
das ist eine ganz normale turnusgemäße
Austausch an der Spitze nachdem es da
eben ja ein bisschen Verwirrung gegeben
hat aber sowas kann passieren stimmen
die Abgeordneten jetzt völlig korrekt
über den Gesetzentwurf der cdu/csu ab
die cdu/csu will im Gegensatz zur Ampel
mit ihrem Gesetz das die Atomkraft in
Deutschland bis mindestens zum Jahre
2024 bis zum Dezember weiter betrieben
werden kann das impliziert auch den
Neukauf von Brennstäben genau das will
ja der ampelgesetz Entwurf nicht der
liegt fest kein neuker auf der
brenzstäbe und
Ausstieg aus der Atomkraft in
Deutschland zum 15 April
2023 das war das was der Bundeskanzler
mit seiner Richtlinienkompetenz im
Streit der Ampel im Oktober entschieden
hat was jetzt hier heute als Gesetz
vorgelegt wurde und was sicherlich
gleich nach den nächsten Abstimmungen
auch als Ergebnis dann vorliegen wird
369 daran sei erinnern ist hier die
Mehrheit im Hause 416 Abgeordnete hat
die Ampel und es ist kein Zweifel daran
dass dieser Gesetzentwurf hier gleich
die Mehrheit bekommen dürfte das
bedeutet dann dass die Laufzeit der
deutschen Atomkraftwerke vom Dezember
auf den April Mitte April genauer gesagt
verlängert wird also eine längere
Laufzeit das ist auch der Grund warum
der ein oder andere grüne
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht mit stimmen
wird es gibt viele persönliche
Erklärungen bei der zweiten Lesung hat
man es ja schon gesehen der ein oder
andere Arm bei den Bündnisgrünen ging
bei nein auch nach oben ja und wir sind
aber hier immer noch in der Abstimmung
über den Gesetzentwurf der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion Wolfgang
Kubicki wird das gleich beenden und dann
geht es tatsächlich um eine
Beschlussempfehlung zum Antrag der AFD
die AFD mit dem großen Ganzen auch eine
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke und
auch weitere Forschung in diesem Bereich
in ihrem Antrag und diese
Beschlussempfehlung
darüber wird gleich abgestimmt und da
ist es anders als bei einem
Gesetzentwurf da gibt es nämlich die
ausschussempfehlung und der Ausschuss
empfiehlt mit seiner Mehrheit dem Antrag
der F AFD nicht zuzustimmen also muss
man dann dementsprechend das
Abgeordneter hier auch sein Kärtchen
einwerfen aber dazu geimpft es gleich
wir wollen ihn aus der Debatte einfach
noch mal zwei Redner zeigen nämlich
Carsten Träger von der SPD und Thomas
ehrhorn von der AFD
deutschland steigt aus der Turm Energie
aus
in genau
100 Tagen ist es soweit und heute am
pulsemörtel
155 Mal werden wir noch wach dann wird
unser Land ein ganzes Stück sicherer
sein
ich weiß ja nicht was sie an diesen 15
April tun werden und bei einigen will
ich es auch gar nicht wissen ich werde
an diesem Tag meine Kinder und meine
Frau umarmen und mit einem Glas Sekt
anstoßen es ist ein Samstag das
gefährliche Kapitel der Kernspaltung zum
Zwecke der Stromerzeugung schließt sich
dann ein für alle Mal in Deutschland
unwiderruflich
endgültig es bleibt beim Ausstieg aus
der domenergie damit ziehen wir einen
Schlussstrich und eine Debatte die uns
durch den Überfall von Putins Armeen auf
die freie Ukraine aufgedrängt wurde
niemand hätte in Deutschland noch
ernsthaft anatomausstieg gerüttelt wenn
ich das Gas als Rückgrat unsere
Energieversorgung innerhalb weniger
Monate komplett ausgefallen wäre seit
dem arbeiten wir mit Hochdruck daran
diese Energieversorgung neu aufzustellen
und was Olaf Scholz gesagt hat ist
richtig wir müssen über diesen Winter
kommen wir beschleunigen deshalb den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien wir
kaufen fossile Energieträger in der
ganzen Welt wir lassen sogar unsere
Kohlekraftwerke länger im Netz wir bauen
flüssiggast terminals in Rekordzeit
inklusive der Infrastruktur im
Hinterland und wir debattieren eben auch
über den sogenannten streckbetrieb
und wir haben lange geprüft und ich
glaube es ist auch unsere Verantwortung
gewesen als Entscheider in diesem Land
dass wir uns diese Entscheidung eben
nicht leicht gemacht haben die üblichen
Verdächtigen haben es natürlich schon
vorher gewusst dass wir jetzt jahrelang
die Atomkraftwerke weiter betreiben
müssen aber die verantwortungsvolle
Seite in diesem Haus hat sich eben
die notwendige Zeit genommen und diesen
Stresstest durchgeführt und er wurde
nicht von den Ministerien durchgeführt
sondern von den Strom betreibenden
Versorgern von den
übertragungsnetzleistern
und am Ende kommt eine Entscheidung die
nicht jedem von uns schmeckt aber
insgesamt ist es richtig den
streckbetrieb den finden wir
verantwortbar und er wird einen Beitrag
dazu leisten dass wir über den Winter
kommen und deshalb beschließen wir heute
dass die restlichen Brennstäbe die in
den Kraftwerken schon sind dass die
insofern ertüchtigt werden dürfen und
bis zum Ende verbraucht werden dürfen
dieses Ende ist der 15 April das
beschließen wir heute nicht mehr und
nicht weniger
der Stresstest der Energiewirtschaft hat
geteilt gezeigt Atomkraft leistet nur
einen kleinen Teil wir wollen uns eben
bestmöglich vorbereiten die Atomkraft
leistet nicht mal einen Anteil zur
Strommenge die wir benötigen sondern sie
leistet einen Teil zur besseren
Verteilung dieses Stroms innerhalb
Deutschlands weil in Bayern zu wenig
Energie erzeugt wird und weil in Bayern
zu wenige Leitungen für den Transport
von norddeutschen Strom in die
energieintensiven Zentren des Landes zur
Verfügung stehen ja Herr sö
hätten sie mal richtig für die Zukunft
Bayerns vorgesorgt dann bräuchten wir
den streckbetrieb nicht machen Sie es
mit sich und ihrem Gewissen aus warum
sie nicht anders gehandelt haben
wir hoffen dass die hoch die
Risikotechnologie die dreieinhalb Monate
noch unfallfrei übersteht denn das muss
man auch mal ehrlich zu Ende denken was
ist denn wenn es nicht gelingt wenn wir
weil wir möglicherweise irgendwelche
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen hinausgezogen
haben uns dann doch mit der Frage
konfrontiert sehen dass ein hoffentlich
nicht eintreten aber was wäre denn wenn
dann doch ein Unfall passiert wer trägt
denn dann die Verantwortung dafür diese
Frage Herr Bilger haben sie nicht
gestellt und sie haben sie auch nicht
beantwortet ich glaube aus guten Gründen
genau sie werden derjenige sein der ist
an uns vorwirft das kann ich mir schon
vorstellen mit der Werberin Jahreszeit
haben wir es dann hoffentlich geschafft
es bleibt beim Atomausstieg wir steigen
ein für alle Mal aus dieser
hochrisikotechnologie aus und dann
können Sie sich von der Union auf den
Kopf stellen mit den Füßen wackeln dann
ist Schluss ein für allemal
und der Bürger
jetzt habe ich nur noch leider 13
Sekunden deswegen
spare ich mir die Replik auf ihre
Ausführungen ich bin froh dass wir heute
einen guten Beschluss fassen werden und
es dann dieses Kapitel ein für alle Mal
beendet ist vielen Dank ich beginne
meine Rede mit zwei Zitaten erstens
Robert Habeck im Jahr 2016 geben Sie uns
noch zwei drei Monate dann regieren wir
diese Republik und dann wird sich
folgendes ändern wir werden Nord Stream
nicht bauen und die Handelsbeziehungen
des gasttransfers zu Russland sukzessive
abbauen weil wir ein Energiewende Land
sind zweites Zitat die niedersächsische
Fraktionschefin der Grünen Julia Willi
Hamburg im September diesen Jahres es
ist ein riesiger Erfolg für die
Bundesregierung dass Deutschland seit 14
Tagen kein Gas mehr aus Russland
importiert was sagt uns das es zeigt uns
das ist schon vor fünf Jahren
Verstand der Grünen Pläne war die
preiswerten russischen gastlieferungen
zu sabotieren und deshalb zeigt es auch
dass schon die ersten einleitenden Sätze
des regierungsantrages falsch sind denn
nicht russland hat künstlich eine
gastnappheit geschaffen sondern sie auf
der Regierungsbank sind es die mit allen
Mitteln diese Lieferung verhindern
wollten und dies durch ihre irre
Sanktionspolitik auch erreicht haben sie
nutzen also ihre verlogene moralpolitik
als Rechtfertigung um ihre eigentlichen
Ziele zu erreichen und eigentlich sollte
es doch auch dem Dümmsten klar sein dass
wir nicht nur in diesem sondern auch in
den kommenden Wintern grundlastfähige
Kernkraftwerke brauchen werden und dass
uns deshalb ein zeitlich begrenzter
streckbetrieb nicht einen Meter
weiterbringt
dass es auch ein Trugschluss ist zu
glauben man müsse nur genügend Windräder
aufstellen dann könne man alles andere
abbauen wenn wir das machen geht halt
bei Flaute das Licht aus das ist doch so
schwer nicht zu verstehen meine Damen
und Herren es sei denn man baut auf den
Import von ausländischen Atomen und
Kohlestrom und begibt sich dann
natürlich in die nächste fatale
Abhängigkeit wenn man dann auch noch
sagt Atomkraft erzeugt zwar kein CO2
wollen wir aber trotzdem nicht
Kohlekraft wollen wir mittelfristig auch
nicht weil es nämlich CO2 erzeugt und
preiswertes russisches Gas wollen wir
schon dreimal nicht weil wir gerne in
Ukraine Krieg zu unserem machen wollen
ja dann ist dies tatsächlich der direkte
Weg in die Zerstörung unserer
Industrienation und der Weg in die
Verarmung unserer Bevölkerung und genau
diesen Weg beschreiben wir ja auch und
deswegen fragen sich immer mehr Menschen
da draußen ob es wirklich denkbar ist
dass es hier eine überwiegend dumme
Politiker Kaste einfach nur dumme
Entscheidungen trifft ich kann sie aber
da draußen beruhigen das ist eben genau
nicht so denn wer die tiefrote wieder
der Grünen Partei und ihre Akteure
durchdrungen hat der weiß dass
mindestens die ideologische
Führungselite ganz genau weiß was sie
tut und wohin der Weg eigentlich gehen
soll und einige sagen das inzwischen
ganz ungeniert ich zitiere die grüne
Wirtschaftsjournalistin der taz Ulrike
Herrmann die sich in einem Vortrag nicht
entblöden konnte folgendes zu sagen man
muss sich klar machen das Klimaschutz
den totalen Umbau bedeutet da bleibt
kein Stein auf dem anderen und dann ist
klar dass das grüne das ist das grüne
Wachstum nicht geben wird sondern was
wir haben werden ist grüne schrumpfen
wir müssen raus aus dem Kapitalismus
eine staatlich gelenkte Privatwirtschaft
plus Rationierung
das ist die Zukunft Zitat Ende wer diese
Zukunft will ja der kann bitte auch
weiter Rot-Grün wählen wer das
allerdings nicht will für den gibt es
Gott sei Dank eine Alternative vielen
Dank wir kommen zu weiteren Abstimmungen
Thomas ehrhorn in der Debatte für die
AFD meine Damen und Herren und da das
ganze hier immer noch ein wenig dauert
wollen wir Ihnen weitere Stimmen
und wirtschaftlich
weitere Stimmen zeigen nämlich Carina
Konrad von der FDP und Ralf lenkert von
der Linksfraktion
auf Drucksache 4000 wir ändern heute das
Atomgesetz
das ist eine Frage der Vernunft diese
Entscheidung die ist unumgänglich
geworden und mit der
Laufzeitverlängerung der drei sicheren
und auch der drei klimaneutralen
Kraftwerke Isar 2 Emsland und
Neckarwestheim 2 wird die
Stromversorgung über den Winter
stabilisiert und darum geht es und die
emotionalen reden der Kollegen Harald
Ebner und Carsten Träger haben ja klar
gemacht dass der Weg hierher nicht
einfach war und er war auch nicht
selbstverständlich aber wir haben ihn
nicht zum Selbstzweck gemacht dass kein
Selbstzweck der Ampel dass diese
Laufzeitverlängerung heute beschlossen
wird bis in den April es geht darum die
Menschen sicher über den Winter zu
bringen und den Menschen die Angst zu
nehmen davor dass der Strom ausfallen
kann abgegebene Stimmkarten 661 mit ja
haben gestimmt 375 mit Nein haben
gestimmt 216
Enthaltungen 70 der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen
ja meine Damen und Herren sie haben es
gehört das kam jetzt etwas plötzlicherer
als erwartet
661 Abgeordnete waren nur muss ich sagen
anwesend bei der wichtigen Abstimmung
über die Frage
atomänderung des Atomgesetzes das war
der Gesetzentwurf der Ampel 375 haben
mit Ja gestimmt 216 mit Nein 70
Enthaltungen das bedeutet dass die Ampel
bei weitem nicht alle ihrer Stimmen
bekommen hat aber es reicht aus wenn
auch nur relativ knapp reicht es aus
über die Mehrheit 369 375 also dieser
Antrags angenommen worden soeben hat
also der Deutsche Bundestag
verabschiedet dass die drei deutschen
Atomkraftwerke über das endursprüngliche
Enddatum
31.12 hinauslaufen werden und dass sie
bis zum 15.4 weiterlaufen können danach
ist dann Schluss mit der Atomkraft in
Deutschland so also der Gesetzentwurf
der Ampel der soeben hier angenommen
wurde und Thomas jazzombeck ist jetzt
der erste Trainer der hier das Wort
ergreift zur Beratung der Fraktion der
Antrag cdu/csu Technologie Agenda neue
Energien Rolle der Wissenschaft in der
Bundesregierung stärken wir reden über
Hilfen für diejenigen die es brauchen
wir reden über sparen und wir reden
darüber Gas aus anderen Staaten zu
beziehen aus den USA per LNG und woher
auch immer meine Damen und Herren das
was ich in dieser Diskussion der letzten
Monate vermisse ist die Frage wie wir
auch mit Technologie dieses Problem
angehen können
wir sind
wir sind wir sind eine ingenieursnation
in Deutschland und wir haben viele
Beiträge geleistet um am Ende die
Menschheit auch nach vorne zu bringen es
beginnt mit dem Buchdruck es geht über
die Glühbirne das Telefon das
Periodensystem Straßenbahn Auto die
Relativitätstheorie der erste Computer
alles Deutsche Erfindungen und sogar die
Goldbären zitiert das Handelsblatt als
eine fundamentale Erfindung und meine
Damen und Herren warum sollten unsere
Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieure unsere
Forscher und Wissenschaftler nicht in
der Lage sein auch für diese Krise
Lösungen zu finden und es gibt sie es
gibt Reife Technologien die in unseren
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen an unseren
Universitäten an unseren Hochschulen für
angewandte Wissenschaften sind und ich
vermisse
die Stimme der Forschungsministerin ich
habe sie in diesem ganzen Kontext nicht
gehört ich vermisse die Ausgaben von
diesen rund 300 Milliarden Euro sind 0
für Technologie vorgesehen alles was Sie
heute tun mit der wasserstoffinitiative
und anderem sind Dinge die wir in der
corona-krise als Budget zur Verfügung
gestellt haben 9 Milliarden alleine für
das Thema Wasserstoff und deshalb meine
Damen und Herren als service-opposition
bieten wir Ihnen heute mal an wie eine
Strategie aussehen sollte diese sich zu
eigen machen müssen wie ich finde wir
brauchen dringend eine technologieagenda
wir brauchen erstens eine
wissenschaftsbasierte schonungslose
Analyse damit muss es beginnen wir
brauchen zum zweiten eine Initiative für
Schnellläufer was können wir kurzfristig
erreichen Technologie heute aus dem
Labor in die Fabrik und wenn es zum
Beispiel Solarzellen sind auf die
Häuserdächer bringen wir brauchen
drittens ein strategischen Ansatz in
dieser ganzen Diskussion wird ständig
darüber geredet wie wir durch diesen
Winter kommen aber vereinfacht
gesprochen meine Damen und Herren womit
wollen wir in fünf Jahren heizen darauf
müssen wir heute die Antwort finden und
auch die richtigen Entscheidungen
treffen und es geht auch um eine
langfristige Perspektive die
langfristige Perspektive sind Themen wie
zum Beispiel Kernfusion wurde der ein
oder andere sagt das ist Zukunftsmusik
sicherlich wird die Kernfusion uns nicht
in den nächsten fünf oder zehn Jahren
hier ein energiebeitrag leisten aber
heute müssen die Entscheidungen
getroffen werden wenn heute nicht die
Entscheidungen für diese Technologie
getroffen werden wo wir gut sind wir
haben zwei spannende Start-ups in
Darmstadt in München wir haben
Wendelstein x wir haben ita wenn heute
nicht die Entscheidung getroffen werden
hier auch zu investieren dann werden die
Talente woanders hingehen in Silicon
Valley nach China und die Technik wird
für uns nicht erschließbar sein
und ich will das auch mal auf diesen
mittelfristigen Zeitraum etwas
konkretisieren drei bis fünf Jahre was
kann man denn da schaffen und wir haben
ja gestern schon über e-fuels und andere
Dinge geredet wenn wir mit den
Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern unsere aos insbesondere
diskutieren sagen sie immer wir brauchen
globale energiepartnerschaften wir haben
so was auch schon begonnen im BMBF als
wir noch in der Regierung waren wir
müssen das jetzt skalieren und das
bedeutet ein Projekt wie beispielsweise
in Patagonien wo tatsächlich am Ende 550
Liter e-fuels in den nächsten Jahren im
industriellen Maßstab gemacht werden
übrigens wird Fördergeldern des BMW i
aus der alten Periode
das sind industrieller Maßstab skalierte
Technologie die Dinge die wir brauchen
und war es der Beitrag der Forschung
ganz einfach es gibt zum Beispiel
Start-ups die gerade auf dieser falling
walls-konferenz sich präsentiert haben
die mit neuen Verfahren deutlich
effizienter messanol aus grüner Energie
erzeugen können was die Basis am Ende
dafür ist genau diese diese Energie nach
Deutschland zu bekommen und wo wir
wirklich ein impact machen können und
können vielleicht aus diesen 550 Litern
e-fuse dieser Anlage zwei oder drei
Milliarden machen und das ist der
Beitrag den die Forschung hier leisten
muss frau Ministerin wir haben ihn in
der letzten Sitzungswoche ein Konzept
gemacht wie sie ein Rettungsschirm für
die Wissenschaft ausbreiten sie hatten
das nicht auf dem Schirm sie sind an dem
Tag der Debatte darauf eingegangen das
war schlau wir haben in der letzten
Sitzungswoche ein Konzept vorgelegt wie
sie 200 Euro an die Studierenden
ausbringen können da haben sie viel zu
spät auf uns gehört deshalb werden sie
nicht zum ersten ersten fertig jetzt
folgen Sie unserem Konzept das ist auch
schlau deshalb appelliere ich an sie
seien sie auch hier klug nehmen Sie
unseren Ball dieser technologieagenda
auf wir können diese Krise nicht lösen
ohne neue Technologie und dort müssen
wir investieren wir müssen es
wissenschaftsbasiert machen und wir
müssen die Köpfe unserer Forscherinnen
und Forscher nutzen um aus dieser Krise
zu kommen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege bevor ich die
nächste Rednerin aufgehende unterbreche
ich die Aussprache und kommt zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 32a-32d
die Zeit für die namentliche Abstimmung
die dritte namentliche Abstimmung ist
vorbei deshalb frage ich ist noch ein
Mitglied des Hauses anwesend dass seine
Stimme nicht abgegeben hat oder noch
nicht abgegeben wird
das ist erkennbar nicht der Fall dann
schließe ich die Abstimmung und bitte
die Schriftführung und Schriftführer mit
der Ausbildung zu beginnen das Ergebnis
der namentlichen Abstimmung wird Ihnen
wie immer später bekannt gegeben
da kommen wir zurück zur 1000 Punkt 33
und ihr Teil als nächster Rednerin der
Kollegin Yvonne Rey SPD-Fraktion das
wäre
und der Bundestag debattiert über die
Rolle der Wissenschaft in der
Bundesregierung bei neuen Energien einen
Antrag der cducson liebe Kolleginnen das
wichtigste direkt am Anfang die
Ampelkoalition schätzt den Rat der
Wissenschaft die Ampelkoalition lässt
sich sowohl bei kurz als auch bei
Mittel- und langfristigen
Herausforderungen von der Wissenschaft
beraten und die Ampelkoalition bezieht
die Wissenschaft in die politische
Entscheidungsfindung ein dafür brauchen
wir nicht erst einen Antrag der
Unionsfraktion und weil ich erwartet
hätte dass die Frage kommt warum hören
sie dann nicht auf die Wissenschaft das
tun wir als eine seiner ersten
Amtshandlungen hat Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz den corona-expert in den Rat
eingesetzt dieser berät die
Bundesregierung seit seit einem Jahr bei
der Bewältigung der corona-pandemie auf
Basis aktueller Forschungserkenntnisse
haben die ExpertInnen bis jetzt 12
Stellungnahmen veröffentlicht diese
Empfehlungen haben wir genutzt und
werden wir auch weiterhin nutzen um
unser Gesundheitssystem auch über die
Pandemie hinaus zu verbessern dank der
Wissenschaft überwinden wir die
corona-pandemie und dank der
Wissenschaft und wir besser auf kommende
Pandemien vorbereitet in diesem Sommer
hat der Zukunftsrat der Bundesregierung
seine Arbeit aufgenommen nicht nur ist
die Geschäftsstelle bei der akatech der
Deutschen Akademie der
technikwissenschaften angesiedelt auch
unter den Teilnehmerinnen sind neben
VertreterInnen aus Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft viele renommierte
wissenschaftler:innen aller
Fachrichtungen es geht um neue
Entwicklungen Erkenntnisse und Trends
um technologische Potenziale und um
Fragen der gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz
es geht darum gemeinsam Antworten auf
die Fragen unserer Zeit zu finden und
Lösungen für die Herausforderungen der
Zukunft dank der Wissenschaft nutzen wir
die Potenziale der Digitalisierung und
weiterer technologischer Innovationen
und dank der Wissenschaft machen wir den
Standort Deutschland innovativer
unabhängiger und nachhaltiger
und wir wissen alle gerade jetzt ist das
wichtiger als je zuvor schließlich
kommen gerade zu einer noch nicht
überstandenen Pandemie eine Inflation
steigende Lebensmittelpreise und die
Angst um die Versorgungssicherheit durch
Strom und Gas hinzu uns ist wichtig dass
diese Herausforderungen nicht zu einer
existenziellen Krise für die Menschen in
unserem Land werden
deshalb gehört zum Abwehrschirm der
Bundesregierung auch eine gaspreisbremse
die die Energiekosten auffangen soll
diese gaspreisbremse greift Empfehlungen
der expertinnenkommission Gas und Wärme
auf die die Bundesregierung genau zu
diesem Zweck für die wissenschaftliche
Erarbeitung von Vorschlägen zur
Ausgestaltung dieser gaspreisbremse
eingerichtet hat auch hier dank der
Wissenschaft unterstützen und entlasten
wir die Menschen in diesem Winter und
auch dank der Wissenschaft stärken wir
den sozialen Zusammenhalt in unserem
Land
und das sind nur drei Beispiele der
vergangenen Monate angesichts der
Exzellenz unserer wissenschaftler:innen
wäre es gerade zu fahrlässig und ehrlich
gesagt auch dumm auf diese Expertise zu
verzichten und ich weiß wovon ich
spreche schließlich komme ich aus Aachen
dem nicht nur mit Abstand schönsten und
europäischen Wahlkreis sondern vor allem
auch der Hochschule und
Wissenschaftsstadt überhaupt
am E.ON Energy Reset Center der RWTH
Aachen zum Beispiel erforschen
wissenschaftler:innen die
Energieversorgung der Zukunft sie
entwickeln nachhaltige Energiequellen
flexible Netze und Speicher und haben
allein dieses Jahr mehrere Studien
veröffentlicht die sich mit der
Abhängigkeit vom russischen Erdgas
befassen und mit der Frage wie wir
dieser Abhängigkeit möglichst schnell
und nachhaltig entkommen können von der
hervorragenden Forschungsarbeit konnte
ich mich bei Gesprächen und vor Ort
besuchen selbst überzeugen
Beispiele wie dieses zeigen wir können
uns darauf verlassen dass die
Wissenschaft schon jetzt an Antworten
arbeitet auf Fragen die wir uns
vielleicht noch gar nicht stellen und
Lösungen entwickelt für
Herausforderungen mit denen wir noch
nicht konfrontiert sind und das sind
sämtlichen Disziplinen Fachrichtungen
und Forschungsfeldern sie sehen
Forschung und Wissenschaft ihre
Erkenntnisse ihre Arbeit und ihre
Ratschläge spielen eine zentrale Rolle
in der Politik der Bundesregierung und
der Ampelkoalition wir wissen um den
unschätzbaren Wert der Wissenschaft wir
vertrauen ihr als unverzichtbare
Partnerin bei der politischen
Entscheidungsfindung die achten ihre
Freiheit und ihre Unabhängigkeit und
stehen fest an ihrer Seite um sie vor
Angriffen und Verleumdungen zu schützen
wir fördern ihre innovativen Ansätze in
die interdisziplinären Kooperationen und
internationale Vernetzung in der
Grundlagenforschung ebenso wie in der
anwendungsorientierten Forschung aber
vor allem wir danken den
wissenschaftler:innen für ihre Neugier
ihre Kritik ihr Durchhaltevermögen ihren
Einsatz und ihren Rat in guten wie auch
in weniger guten Zeiten
und
nachdem ich mich als öcherin und somit
als Rheinländerin geoutet habe und es
nach elf ist möchte ich diese
Gelegenheit noch nutzen allen Jecken in
ein fröhliches Alarm zu wünschen und als
persönliches Angebot an meinen Kollegen
an meinen Düsseldorfer Kollegen jetzt
schonbeck ein leicht leiseres Helau an
alle vielen Dank
ja Alaaf und Helau auch hier im
Deutschen Bundestag übrigens für jedes
konnten sie nicht sehen um 11 Uhr 11 hat
Wolfgang Kubicki ebenfalls darauf
hingewiesen dass jetzt Karneval sei aber
doch bitte nicht hier im Hohen Hause
aber so viel Zeit muss sein als rein
Inder habe ich persönlich volles
Verständnis dafür Michael Kaufmann jetzt
von der AFD
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
ein Antrag der die Forschung stärkt
speziell im Bereich der
Energieversorgung trifft bei uns immer
auf offene Ohren sie haben Recht Herr
jazzonbeck es fehlt der
Forschungspolitik der Regierung an einer
klaren Strategie aber was in aller Welt
hat sie dabei geritten die fraglos
vorhandenen guten Ansätze dadurch zu
entwerten dass sie zwar einerseits von
einer unabhängigen ergebnisoffenen
Analyse und Ideologie freier
Bestandsanalyse sprechen aber dann die
Debatte doch wieder auf sogenannte
erneuerbare das heißt überwiegend
wetterabhängige Formen der Energie zu
Verzollung zu verengen
in der vorliegenden Form hätte dieser
Antrag beinahe auch von den Grünen
kommen können
genau so schlimm wo bleibt die
ergebnisoffene und Ideologie freie
Prüfungen Förderung von neuen
verbesserten Filtersystemen für Kohle
und Gaskraftwerke
wo bleibt wo bleibt die Entwicklung von
co2-speichertechnik im Zusammenhang mit
konventionellen Kraftwerken und nicht
zuletzt wo bleibt die
kernenergie-forschung die mit den neuen
Reaktor Technologien der Generationen 4
und 5 einen substanziellen Beitrag
sowohl zur Versorgungssicherheit als
auch zum Erreichen der Klimaziele
leisten könnte
immerhin
immerhin haben sie wenigstens die
Kernfusion als eine der Form der
Kernkraft in ihre Darstellung mit
einbezogen auch wenn gerade diese
Technologie in einer noch relativ ferne
Zukunft weist wenn Sie nun in ihrem
Antrag die Möglichkeit der Nutzung von
Sonnenenergie in Ländern hoher
Sonneneinstrahlung ins Spiel bringen
unterschlagen Sie dass Deutschland sich
damit einmal mehr in eine Abhängigkeit
von Ländern begeben würde die schon
morgen keine zuverlässigen Partner mehr
sein könnten ganz abgesehen davon müssen
die dort erzeugten Energieträger ja
irgendwie hier herkommen der damit
verbunden enorme Schadstoffausstoß der
Tankschiff gekannten für die mehr von
der grünen Energie dann vollends
absurdum
die deutsche
die deutsche Energiepolitik muss endlich
die richtigen Prioritäten setzen das
bedeutet vor allem zweierlei erstens wir
brauchen Energieträger deren Ertrag wir
kontrollieren können und die eine
stabile Grundversorgung gewährleisten
das ist bei Sonne und Wind nicht der
Fall zweitens wir müssen uns von
Autokraten und potenziell unsicheren
Partnern weitgehend unabhängig machen
Energieversorgung ist das Rückgrat der
deutschen Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
deshalb braucht es eine ideologiefreie
und ergebnisoffene Prüfung aller
Optionen und nicht nur solcher die
gerade dem Links-
und natürlich haben sie recht dass es
der Forschungspolitik der Regierung an
einer clantrage gefehlt und das hier
dringend Abhilfe nötig ist aufgrund der
erkennbaren ideologischen Verengung
Ihres Antrags sehen wir diesen trotzdem
mit großer Skepsis und und empfehlen
Ihnen diesen zu überarbeiten und
wirklich Technologie offen zu gestalten
Deutschland kann sich keine Scheuklappen
und Denkverbote mehr leisten
im Ausschuss zur Bildung und Forschung
wurde der Nobelpreisträger Steven Schuh
ehrend erwähnt nicht zuletzt auch von
ihnen
hat auf der Jahrestagung der
helmholtzgesellschaft im September den
Hauptvortrag gehalten und dabei der
Bundespolitik folgende Warnung mit
Hinblick auf erneuerbarer Energien und
insbesondere mit Hinblick auf die
Wasserstofftechnik ins Stammbuch
geschrieben ich zitiere
überlegen Sie sich sehr genau ob sie die
Industrien töten wollen die Deutschland
seinen Reichtum bescheren Zitat Ende
genau diese Warnung haben sie mit ihrem
einseitigen Antrag in den Wind
geschlagen danke
vielen Dank Herr Kollege hinterbrecher
neu die Aussprache und komme zurück zu
den Tagesordnungspunkten 32A bis
32d ich konnte zunächst zu TOP 32b und
Liebe in das Ergebnis der namentlichen
Abstimmung in der zweiten Beratung über
den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der
cdu/csu Entwurf eines 19 Gesetzes zur
Änderung des Atomgesetzes 19 ist Tom
Änderungsgesetz Drucksachen 20 34 88 und
20 43 57 bekannt abgegebene Stimmkarten
655 mit ja haben gestimmt 242 mit Nein
haben gestimmt
413 Enthaltungen keine der Gesetzentwurf
ist in zweiter Beratung damit abgelehnt
damit entfällt nach der Geschäftsführung
des Deutschen Bundestages die dritte
Beratung wir kommen zu TOP 32c das
Ergebnis der namentlichen Abstimmung
über die Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses für Umwelt- und
Verbraucherschutz
zum Antrag der Abgeordneten Doktor
Rainer Kraft Carsten Hilse mag Bernhard
weitere Abgeordneten und der Fraktion
der AFD Horizont erweitern keine Energie
für umweltfreundliche sichere und
kostengünstige Energieversorgung
Drucksachen 2032 und 20 763
abgegebene Stimmkarten 654 mit ja haben
gestimmt 581 mit Nein haben bestimmt 73
Enthaltungen keine damit ist die
Beschlussempfehlung angenommen wir
kommen zurück ja das waren also die
Ergebnisse der Abstimmung zur Frage
Atomenergie die cdu/csu hatte ja in
ihrem Gesetzentwurf gefordert dass die
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland bis zum
31.12 24 weiterlaufen sollten
242 Jahre stimmen das sind mehr als die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat aber hat halt nicht
ausgereicht und der Antrag der AFD wurde
ebenfalls abgelehnt interessant noch aus
meiner Sicht das die anwesenden
Abgeordneten von Abstimmung zur
Abstimmung
immer weniger wurden das ist eigentlich
auch keine so schöne Entwicklung beim
Antrag der Ampel der dann angenommen
wurde eben bei dem Gesetzentwurf muss
ich sagen der Ampel waren es immerhin
noch 661 Abgeordnete und dieser Antrags
angenommen worden die Atomkraft in
Deutschland wird verlängert bis zum 15
April und danach ist Schluss es wird
keine neuen bremsstäbe mehr geben das
ist das was der Bundestag hier heute
abgestimmt hat jetzt geht's weiter in
der Debatte Rolle der Wissenschaft in
der Bundesregierung bei neuen Energien
und Anna Christmann für die
Bündnisgrünen hat das Wort
Windkraft Solarenergie all die
Entwicklungen die ja schon da sind dann
ist es natürlich auch wichtig dass wir
diese Technologien auch tatsächlich
einsetzen und die Energiewende in der
Praxis tun und nicht nur über das
sprechen was vielleicht irgendwann mal
passieren könnte beides ist wichtig und
da sehe ich eben einen gewissen
Widerspruch zum Antrag wenn man
einerseits einfordert noch viel mehr
Innovationsförderung zu tun was ich
richtig finde grundsätzlich auf der
anderen Seite wir aber in der Lage jetzt
sind weil all diese Energie Innovationen
in den letzten Jahren eben nicht
eingesetzt worden sind und ich will das
noch mal sagen bei der Windkraft haben
wir eine regelrechte altmaierdelle zu
verzeichnen wenn man noch mal vergleicht
2017 wurden noch
1792 Windkraftanlagen auf dem Land
gebaut 2021 nur noch 484 also nur noch
ein Drittel davon die Genehmigungen sind
runtergegangen um 40 Prozent 2020 im
Vergleich zu 2015 die überhaupt nur
genehmigt worden sind also hier haben
wir eine Innovation letztlich ist
Windkraft auch eine Technologie die über
die letzten Jahre immer verbessert
worden ist die wir zur Verfügung haben
und dann muss es doch unser erstes Ziel
auch sein diese auch einzusetzen und das
ist das was diese Bundesregierung mit
einem ganz neuen Energie voranbringt im
Gegensatz zu der alten
und das hat im übrigen auch was mit
Innovationen zu tun weil natürlich auch
das Anreize setzt für Energie
Innovationen und diese zu entwickeln
wenn der Staat dann auch derjenige ist
der sie einkauft wie er richtig gesagt
ankerkunde und dann auch einsetzt und
das machen wir natürlich für diese
Bereiche jetzt wir haben mit dem
osterpaket ein Gesetzespaket
verabschiedet im Energiebereich das so
groß war wie lange lange Zeit nicht wir
haben gerade eine offshore-vereinbarung
für Windenergie gemacht am 3.11 Minister
Robert Habeck wir haben einen
wärmepumpengipfel veranstaltet und der
den Hochlauf der Wärmepumpen organisiert
das alles sind ganz konkrete Schritte
bestehende Energie Innovationen in die
Praxis zu bringen und das ist das was
die nächsten Jahre ganz konkret für den
Klimaschutz zählt
und dann will ich aber natürlich auch
sagen dass wir das Ziel ausdrücklich
teilen dass wir dabei natürlich nicht
stehen bleiben da geht es darum quasi
das was wir haben möglichst zügig
auszurollen was versäumt worden ist in
den letzten Jahren und dann geht es aber
und da stimme ich ausdrücklich zu
natürlich darum parallel auch diese
Dinge zu entwickeln die noch kommen
können wo wir noch besser werden können
wo wir vielleicht noch effizientere
Technologien noch klimafreundliche
Energien entwickeln können und deswegen
haben wir uns das ja auch gerade im
Forschungsbereich ganz explizit so
vorgenommen wir haben eine
Zukunftsstrategie verabredet im
Koalitionsvertrag und da ist die erste
Mission genau das was sie ja mit Ihrem
Eintrag vorschlagen also den Vorschlag
hatten wir schon bevor er offenbar
eingefallen ist auch noch in einen
CDU-Antrag aufzunehmen die Mission ist
im Koalitionsvertrag genauso beschrieben
dass Sie moderne Technologien für eine
wettbewerbsfähige und klimaneutrale
Industrie und die Sicherstellung
sauberer Energiegewinn und Versorgung
zum Ziel hat und dort werden wir genau
das tun es geht darum in einer Mission
mit einer klaren Projektsteuerung
ressortübergreifend für erneuerbare
Energien die Forschungs- und
innovationstätigkeiten zu bündeln die
uns eben auch die langfristige
energiesicherung erneuerbar in den
nächsten Jahren sichern werden
und diese Zukunftsstrategie wird ja
jetzt gerade auf den Weg gebracht und
ich möchte auch da vielleicht noch mal
den Vergleich zu dem Handeln der letzten
Bundesregierung bringen denn da hatten
wir ja eine Hightech-Strategie und auch
da standen ja schon viele nette Dinge
drin die sich gut angehört haben auch
was kreisläuft Wirtschaft angeht etc
aber auch dort hat es eben an der
Umsetzung gemangelt und diesen Schritt
wollen wir jetzt mit der
Zukunftsstrategie sehr viel besser
machen dadurch dass wir eben Missionen
einführen genau wie diese das werden wir
ja auch in anderen Bereichen tun wie zum
Beispiel auch bei künstlicher
Intelligenz Digitalisierung die ja auch
eine Auswirkung auf Energietechnologien
haben da gibt es natürlich Bezüge und
damit dass wir aber eine
Projektsteuerung auch für diese
Missionen einsetzen werden
ressortübergreifend gemeinsam mit der
Wissenschaft werden wir auch dafür
sorgen dass diese Innovationen die in
der Mission entwickelt werden dann eben
auch in die Praxis gelangen und uns
wirklich helfen den Energiebereich eben
auch zu deagonisieren in den nächsten
Jahren
darüber hinaus gibt es viele Dinge fürs
Innovationssystem die wichtig sind wir
haben im Juli eine start-up-strategie
vorgelegt in der ein zentraler
Mechanismus in der Finanzierung die ja
auch angesprochen wird im Antrag ist
dass wir einen neuen Fonds aufsetzen den
deeptec and clyded climate also mit
einem klaren Ziel dort eben tatsächlich
auch in Start-ups zu investieren die
klimale Technologien entwickeln die neue
Energietechnologien entwickelt das ist
eine Aktivität die wir jetzt sehr
konkret in diesem Bereich voranschreiten
zusammen mit der start-up-strategie mit
der Zukunftsstrategie mit der
Entfesselung der Sprint machen wir genau
das was Sie vorschlagen schon längst wir
bringen das innovationsökosystem auf den
Weg dass uns auch für den Energiebereich
die Innovationen sichern wird die wir
neben dem akuten Ausbau die nächsten
Jahre brauchen werden vielen dank vielen
Dank Frau Kollegin
dass man nächste Rednerin ist die
Kollegin Dr Petra Sitte Fraktion
Petra citys Sprecherin für Forschung
Technologie und herr Präsident meine
Damen Innovationspolitik
mein Gott jetzt hat sie es die Union hat
endlich die Dringlichkeit einer
nachhaltigen modernen Energieversorgung
erkannt was sie vorschlagen erinnert
zugleich an eine ziemlich alte
unionsförderung das ich zitiere die
Bundesregierung nicht allein nicht auf
ein
kriegskrisenmanagement allein im
aktuellen Versorgungsengpass sich
beschränken dürfen an sie von wann die
Forderung ist von 1973 jo mitten in der
damaligen Ölkrise haben sie das
beantragt dann floss doch noch ziemlich
viel Öl durch die Pipelines später
forderten sie ist die Tiere wieder die
Bundesregierung muss ein in sich
schlüssiges und nachhaltiges
Energiekonzept vorlegen dass die
Behandlung aller noch offenen
Problemfelder beinhaltet auch eine
vernünftige forder diesmal von 1999 aber
in 32 Regierungsjahren nachts 1973 hat
die Union nichts vorgelegt was man
wirklich als belastbares Konzept hätte
bezeichnen können
stattdessen
stattdessen haben sie gegen das
erneuerbare Energien gesetzt gezetert
ohne Ende wir haben über windmonster im
Nebel geplabert sie haben wahrlich eher
eine vernebelte Sichtachse auf
erneuerbare Energien entwickelt meine
Damen und Herren
später später später machen wir alles im
Ausschuss meine Damen und Herren wir
hatten in Deutschland Mal weltweit eine
führende Solarbranche nicht nur die Wind
den Windbereich Sachsen-Anhalt
beispielsweise mein Bundesland aus dem
ich komme boomte in solar Valley diese
Branche hat Schwarz-Gelb praktisch über
Nacht die Förderung gekippt seitdem
werden in Deutschland vor allem
chinesische Solarpanels verbaut wenn wir
nachhaltig die Energieversorgung sichern
wollen dann müssen wir eben auch
Solarbranche und Forschung dazu in
Deutschland stärken
und das gilt das gilt natürlich erst
recht für die Zeit nach der
Versorgungskrise der Umstieg auf
erneuerbare Energien ist unverzichtbar
meine Damen und Herren bei den
unionsförderungen nach Konzepten und
Analysen beschleicht mich bisweilen das
Gefühl sie wollen eigentlich nichts
wirklich im Hier und Heute tun
schließlich haben wir doch im Umstieg
und Frau Christmann und die Kollegin von
der SPD hat schon darauf hingewiesen
haben wir doch für den Umstieg auf einer
nachhaltige Energieversorgung nicht
zuerst das Problem fehlender
Erkenntnisse nee nee das haben wir nicht
viel mehr werden die bereits gewonnenen
Erkenntnisse schlicht nicht umgesetzt
ich erinnere mal daran dass der Club auf
Rom unter dem Titel Grenzen des
Wachstums von
1972 bereits auf diesen Umstand
hingewiesen hat
1972 forderte diese zum ersten Mal eine
radikale Energiewende die Wissenschaft
hat sich seitdem jahrzehntelang mit
ihrem Wissen an Bundesregierung und
Bundesregierung relevant aber es
passierte entschieden zu wenig das ist
das Problem und das muss ich ändern
dann machen weitere Forschungen
tatsächlich Sinn so wie es Frau
Christmann angedeutet hat zu
Speichertechnologien beispielsweise zu
Energieeffizienz oder eben auch zu
intelligenten Netzen beispielsweise
zugleich aber muss eben auch aufhören
Stadtwerke und Energiegenossenschaften
beispielsweise Steine in den Weg zu
legen wenn Sie moderne wenn sie
erneuerbare Energieformen einsetzen
wollen wenn Sie moderne Technologien
einsetzen wollen auch wenn dabei die
großen Energiekonzerne mit den
zähnenknirschen es geht auch um in
dezentrale Aufstellung des gesamten
Energiesystems ich schließe meine Rede
mit den Worten des
UN-Generalsekretärs Antonio guterisch
Selbstverpflichtungen zu null Emissionen
sind Null Wert ohne Pläne und taten um
sie umzusetzen also die Energiewende ist
heute dringender denn je und dafür muss
die öffentliche Hand kraftvoll
investieren zeitenwände ist eben auch
Energiewende
sagt Petra Sitte für die Linksfraktion
der nächste Redner kommt von der FDP
Stefan Seite er ist Sprecher für
Forschung Technologie und Innovation
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir reden heute über das Thema neue
Energien wir reden über das Thema
Wissenschaft und ich habe den Antrag der
CDU und CSU mit Interesse gelesen weil
ich sehr wichtig finde dass wir gerade
jetzt in der Phase wo unser
hauptaugenmerken wenn sie auf die Liste
der Debatten in diesem Haus schauen auf
kurzfristige Bewältigung der Krise ist
finde ich es wichtig dass wir auch uns
über die langfristige Entwicklung
Gedanken machen dass wir darüber reden
wie sie der Weg letztendlich in die
nächsten Jahren aus und deswegen habe
ich eigentlich auch das schön gefunden
dass ich zu diesem Antrag reden darf
aber dann habe ich ein bisschen beim
Lesen den anfangs verloren und ich werde
Ihnen auch versuchen zu erläutern warum
es geht um ein sehr wichtiges Thema es
geht um Vorausschau es geht letztendlich
um Strategie mein erster Kritikpunkt da
schließe ich mich meinen Vorrednerinnen
weitgehend an ist das Thema diese
Regierung hört auf die Wissenschaft ja
das machen wir nämlich vom ersten Tag an
diese Regierung hat diese spricht über
die Zukunftsstrategie der Entwurf liegt
vor Frau Christmann hat schon darauf
hingewiesen dort ist genau eine Mission
drin die sich mit diesem Thema neue
Energien beschäftigt auch da kann man
sagen wer hat es erfunden da waren wir
jetzt etwas früher dran aber das sind
zeitliche Unterschiede okay die kann man
schwer bewerten das sind vielleicht
nicht so wichtig aber man sollte darauf
hinweisen dass eben jetzt nichts Neues
kommt ich werde nachher noch darauf
eingehen was mich aber mehr an diesem
Antrag irritiert hat ist
ich nenne es mal die Methodik
und da bin ich vielleicht auch nicht
immer zwingend mit allem ganz einig was
die Vorrednerinnen gesagt haben aber es
geht ja um das Thema Technologie und
technologieoffenheit
und wenn ich dann durch diesen Antrag
durchgehe dann beschleicht mich so ein
bisschen das Gefühl also so richtig
soziale Marktwirtschaft ist da
eigentlich nicht immer drin und ich
möchte Ihnen erläutern warum
das Thema Ordnungspolitik wird ja
normalerweise von der Union sehr hoch
gehalten aber wenn wir uns diesen Antrag
anschauen dann stellen wir fest dass zum
Beispiel eine Forderung enthalten ist
die sagt es sollen technologische Ziele
aufgestellt werden und das sind fünf
zehn fünfzehn Jahresschritten
da könnte man jetzt natürlich wenn man
es etwas salopp ausdrücken wollte sagen
okay gut bei Ordnungspolitik herzlich
willkommen beim 5-Jahres-Plan das möchte
ich der CDU an der Stelle gar nicht
unterstellen und da können wir auch im
Ausschuss gerne darüber reden aber ich
möchte an der Stelle noch mal
eindrücklich darauf hinweisen es geht um
technologieoffenheit wir wollen ja nicht
oder wir können jetzt noch nicht wissen
welche Technologie wird in 15 Jahren die
richtige sein wir können Sie auch nicht
vorher bestimmen sondern wir müssen
letztendlich die Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen und es ist ja auch Ziel der
Regierungspolitik insbesondere auch im
Bundesforschungsministerium dass wir
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen das
technologieoffenheit vorhanden ist
sprich wir schaffen die
Rahmenbedingungen und dann sollten wir
es denjenigen überlassen die die Sache
am besten beherrschen das sind unsere
ForscherInnen das sind unsere Menschen
die in den Laboren arbeiten das sind die
Unternehmen ohne sind letztendlich auch
die Kunden die über Technologien mit
vermeiden sprich das Staat soll
letztendlich die Funktion haben
Rahmenbedingungen zu setzen und wenn ich
dann in ihrem Antrag weitergehe dann
finde ich plötzlich das Wort ankerkunde
und Anker Kunde ist ein interessantes
Konzept das macht man zum Beispiel bei
Einkaufszentren wenn es darum geht einen
großen Flex Store mit reinzukriegen ich
hoffe ich habe es richtig gesagt
Reinhard dass man letztendlich an
Attraktion ausübt aber bei einer Frage
welche Technologie wir letztendlich
auswählen wollen müssen wir uns die
Frage stellen wann kommt dieser
ankokunde tatsächlich zum Tragen zu
Beginn des Lebenszyklus einer
Technologie eines Produkts oder
irgendwann und welche Aufgabe wird diese
ankerkunde machen wird er uns einen
sogenannten log-in-effekt bescheren dass
wir uns in eine Technologie
festschreiben die vielleicht gar nicht
die tolle Energie tolle Technologie ist
sondern vielleicht verhindert dass wir
eine bessere Lösung finden also auch
darüber sollten wir vielleicht im
weiteren diskutieren es geht also um die
Frage Wettbewerb um bei den Technologien
nicht um Abnahmegarantien und bitte
nicht um das Thema picking the winners
zwar gibt es genug historische Beispiele
in diesem Land und dann wird das Thema
Wagniskapital aufgegriffen ja der Staat
hat bei dem Thema Wagniskapital eine
Möglichkeit aber sollten wir uns doch
nicht auch überlegen in der
Verantwortung über Steuergelder wer
entscheidet letztendlich über eine
effiziente Verwendung von Mitteln die
wir in unserer Volkswirtschaft haben und
auch da es stellt sich mir die Frage wie
viel Staat fordert dieser Antrag das
wird mir an dieser Stelle letztendlich
nicht deutlich also wenn ich es etwas
zusammenfassen möchte könnte ich sagen
und bitte liebe Kollegen von der CDU
selbst mir nah es ist jetzt einfach ein
bisschen auch dem vielleicht dem Tag
gewidmet 11.11 der in drei Antrag
enthält vieles was sich denke gut ist
oder vieles was vielleicht insbesondere
für die CDU neu ist
aber das Gute ist nicht zwingend immer
neu und ist neu ist nicht zwingend gut
und deswegen lassen sie mich zum
Abschluss sagen wir brauchen in der
Phase des neuen systemwettbewerbs
technologisches Souveränität wir
brauchen Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
Klimawandel dafür brauchen wir
Technologien und Innovationen aber nicht
vorherbestimmt dass es die einzige
Technologie ist sondern der Weg ist die
ökosoziale Marktwirtschaft der
Wettbewerb der Ideen die Schaffung
Innovationen und das denke ich sollte
unser gemeinsames Ziel sein vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Seite
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Thomas
Heilmann CDU-Fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
Frau Ministerin guten Morgen und das
sage ich im doppelten Wortsinn denn dass
wir hier eigentlich versuchen ist ein
Weckruf ein Weckruf weil die
Wissenschaftsszene eindeutig unzufrieden
ist und die Energiebranche
ist es eindeutig auch und die bisherigen
reden der Koalition waren auch weniger
reden als Ausreden bin ich ehrlich bin
liebe Frau Christmann sie haben die
Leistungen des Wirtschaftsministeriums
dargestellt und ich muss ja zugeben die
haben wenigstens ihre Hausaufgaben
gemacht nicht immer mit der Bestnote
aber sie haben welche gemacht denn hier
gibt es keine
und der Seite sie haben lange über die
Anker kundenphilosophiert und stelle
fest dass da offensichtlich auch ein
Unterschied innerhalb ihrer Koalition
gibt den Frau Christmann hat sich ganz
anders geäußert dass sie ich versuchen
die beiden wesentlichen Aspekte die
kurzfristigen und die langfristigen noch
mal auseinander zu nehmen und zu sagen
wo eigentlich das Problem liegt
sie können nichts diese Koalition kann
nichts für diese akute Energiekrise
niemand bezweifelt dass man darauf nicht
vorbereitet war und schon gar nicht weil
das die ist daran die Ampelkoalition
zusehen aber so war es bei der
corona-krise ja auch
und ich habe gar nicht verstanden dass
sie jetzt den klimaex den
corona-expertenrat zitiert haben weil
genau etwas ähnliches fordern wir ja
gerade für die Frage wie gewinnen jetzt
kurzfristig damit um der der von der
alten Koalition eingesetzte Expertenrat
für Klimafragen sagt in dem Titel seines
letzten Gutachtens dass das ist klar
nicht ausreichen wird
was was wir bisher geschafft haben ich
bin Mitglied des Beirates der
Bundesnetzagentur das sind ja auch
fdp-kollegen drin
wir stehen vor ganz vielen ungelösten
Fragen die sich so kurzfristig jetzt
ergeben haben weil wir eben einen von
Putin angezettelten energiekrieg haben
und werden Sie sich doch alle daran
erinnern dass wir in der Schlussphase
der Regierungszeit Merkel jede Woche
Experten gehört haben zum Thema was
machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich ist
einfach von dieser Regierung in dieser
Frage gar nicht zu hören es gibt sehr
schöne Bekenntnisse zu Wissenschaft von
ihnen die würde ich auch alle
unterschreiben
auch die FDP tut das wunderbar ich habe
mir das in der Vorbereitung
aufgeschrieben auf ihrer Webseite steht
wir bekennen uns zum wichtigen Beitrag
der Wissenschaft im demokratischen
Beratungsprozessen um faktenbasierte
Entscheidungen zu ermöglichen in unserer
Lernenden Demokratie sind
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse eine
unverzichtbare Grundlage ja genau
richtig und warum tun sie das in der
Energiekrise nicht also es gibt dazu
überhaupt gar keine keinen Dialog obwohl
die Frage kurzfristig gibt es offene
Fragen und es gibt mittelfristig oft die
Gefahren wir wissen doch alle dass das
Konzept des Umbaus zur erneuerbaren
Energien dass die Energie Lücken die
sich ergeben mit Gaskraftwerken
kurzfristig gelöst werden sollen das
Konzept ist jetzt bei der Frage wir
kriegen kein günstiges Gas oder kein
günstiges Pipeline Gas über Russland
vorsichtig formuliert angegriffen und
dann müssen wir uns doch jetzt mal über
die Frage unterhalten wie funktioniert
denn diese Transformation und alle
Gremien die es dazu gibt sagen wir haben
dazu wenig zu antworten es gibt aber
keinerlei
systematische Aufarbeitung wie kommen
wir denn zu diesen Ergebnissen aufs
Forschung und wissenschaftspolitischer
Hinsicht das hat nichts mit der Frage zu
tun was das bmwk macht sondern das ist
natürlich eindeutig Aufgabe des
Ministeriums für Forschung und
Wissenschaft der wird Klimarat sagt 50%
der techn die wir 2050 brauchen sind
noch nicht fertig entwickelt was für
eine Agenda für einen
Wissenschaftsministerium wir hören dazu
nichts wenn Sie mir nicht glauben ich
habe
dann glauben sie vielleicht Ulrike Gothe
von den Grünen die angesichts dieser
Unklarheiten der Zukunft für Forschung
und Forschungsförderung gerade
öffentlich gesagt hat letzte Woche es
sei ein Affront des Bundes gegenüber dem
Wissenschaftsrat ich meine klarer können
doch die die Äußerungen aus der
Betroffenen Energiebranche aus der in
der Betroffenen Energieforschung aus von
einer grünen Wissenschaftsministerin aus
dem Land Berlin nicht sein und in
Vorbereitungen dieser Rede habe ich
gesagt naja vielleicht habe ich auch
irgendwas verpasst also man kriegt ja
manchmal nicht mit und dann hat was
macht man dann man googelt und Frau
stark Watzinger ich habe ihren Namen
gegoogelt in Kombination mit
energietransformation ich habe vier
Einträge gefunden über ein ganzes Jahr
und dann habe ich Energieforschung
eingegeben war auch nicht besser und
wenn sie nicht in Karlsruhe gewesen
wären offensichtlich Ende
Oktober die ja zur Energieforschung
tätig sind weil das zuständige Kit dann
werden die Einträge noch viel weniger
gewesen
im Verwaltungsrecht gibt es die
Möglichkeit der sogenannten
Untätigkeitsklage das gibt es eine
Politikbetrieb leider nicht aber das was
wir mit unserem Antrag sagen wollen ist
nutzen Sie in der aktuellen Energiekrise
die Wissenschaft viel stärker es gibt
viele unklare fragen wir werfen nicht
vor dass die Fragen unklar sind wir
werfen ihn aber vor dass sie die
Wissenschaft nicht anständig einbinden
deswegen bitte fangen sie an zu handeln
die Energie und Klimakrise ist zu
wichtig als dass wir die Wissenschaft
nicht aktiv in unserem Politikbetrieb
einbinden vielen Dank
Thomas Heimann war das für die cdu/csu
der nächste Redner hier in der Debatte
über die Rolle der Wissenschaft in der
Bundesregierung bei neuen Energien ist
Holger Becker von der SPD ist Mitglied
im Ausschuss für Bildung Forschung und
technologie-
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sie kennen
sicherlich die folgende Situation sie
sind im Urlaub und morgens an Pool wenn
die Anlage öffnet rennt ein paar
Touristen wie von der Tarantel gestochen
zu den Liegen werfen dort ein Handtuch
drauf
warum ich Ihnen das erzähle
Beitrag der Wissenschaft zur Lösung der
aktuellen Energiekrise so lautet der
Antrag der hier ursprünglich besprochen
werden sollte und das war ihr Handtuch
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union dass sie erst mal auf die Liege
geworfen haben nach dem Motto erstmal
Debatte anmelden zeitlos sichern uns
fällt dann sicherlich was ein nun
diskutieren nun diskutieren wir hier
einen Antrag mit einem ganz anderen
Zungenschlag zunächst würde ich ihnen
tatsächlich auch zugestehen dass der
Titel ihres Antrages zum Teil ganz in
meinem Sinne als Wissenschaftler ist
nämlich die Rolle von Wissenschaft in
der Regierung zu stärken und hier und da
wie auch Kollege Seiter schon angemerkt
hat sind Elemente dabei die sind auch
nicht schlecht wir sind aber eben auch
nicht neu ein paar Beispiele Startups
und KMU zu fördern wie in Punkt 12
genannt ist eigentlich immer ein
ratsames vorgehen denn KMU sind
Start-ups sind der Maschinenraum der
deutschen Wirtschaft es freut mich dass
sie das erkannt haben nachdem ihr
letzter Wirtschaftsminister ja eher eine
holpriges Verhältnis in diese Richtung
hatte
ich denke allerdings da stoßen wir mit
der bereits vorliegenden
start-up-strategie natürlich schon ganz
bedeutende Entwicklungen an es gibt
bereits heute im Bereich Innovationen in
der Energiewende über 100 junge
Unternehmen in diesem Land die uns an
den verschiedensten Stellen mit den
verschiedensten Technologien ganz
entscheidend voranbringen und nicht
umsonst waren wir als SPD-Fraktion im
Rahmen unserer Klausur in Dresden zum
Beispiel bei einem Unternehmen zu Gast
das Anlagen zur Wasserstoff Elektrolyse
herstellt
mit der Sprint haben wir zudem bereits
heute ein Instrument das genau jene
schnelle Umsetzung dieses from Lab to
Fab wie sie sehr schön in Punkt 3
formuliert haben bereits als
Arbeitsauftrag hat auch ihr Punkt 7
indem sie das sogenannte pre-commercial
procurement also den Start als
ankerkunden vorschlagen ist schon längst
Teil des Regierungshandelns auch dem ist
in der start-up-strategie dass ich ein
eigenes Kapitel gewidmet
nun nun gut was was steht denn sonst
noch so da sie fordern die
Bundesregierung auf eine
technologieagenda neue Energien zu
erstellen das klingt ganz spannend aber
was ist es denn das stellen wir nämlich
nicht da weiter geht der Satz in Punkt 1
nämlich nicht
und sie nehmen auch nur ein einziges Mal
bei Punkt 8 nämlich konkret Bezug auf
eine sogenannte auf dieser Agenda wenn
es um Vergabe geht und auch da ist es so
dass natürlich Start-ups und KMU's bei
Forschungsvorhaben bereits jetzt schon
besonders zum zugekommen das ist geübte
Praxis bei Förderrichtlinien sie fordern
zudem ein ich zitiere strategischen
Prozess mit einer Ideologie freien
evidenzbasierten Bestandsanalyse
aufzusetzen
das klingt auch erstmal gut aber wie so
oft schlägt der Teufel im Detail wenn
die Union nämlich von Ideologie frei
spricht ist zu befürchten dass sie das
genaue Gegenteil meint sie stellen sich
hin und fordern Ideologie Freiheit bei
Energiefragen aber wie sieht es bei
ihnen selbst aus in meinem Land in
Thüringen bekämpft die Union natürlich
völlig Ideologie frei mit Windkraft mit
Zähnen und Klauen und das gestrige
Urteil des Bundesgerichtshof hat hier
glücklicherweise positiv eingegriffen
auch
auf die AFD dass wenn man das die AFD
das multidimensional tote Pferd der
sogenannten friedlichen Nutzung der
Kernenergie reiten möchte wundert mich
nicht die vorangegangene Abstimmung in
diesem Haus hat hier einen
typischerweise eine deutliche Stimme
gesprochen und fragen Sie mal die Leute
bei Helmholtz die ja wirklich
Energieforschung machen da werden sie
niemand finden der diesem Thema auch nur
ein Mühe Zukunftspotenzial zuordnet
was haben wir denn sonst noch unter
Punkt 6 sprechen sie von Forschung
Entwicklung im Bereich der
Speichertechnologien und auch davon sich
neue Ansätze im Bereich Kernfusion
genauer anzuschauen keine schlechte Idee
genau zu diesen Punkten liegen dem Büro
für Technikfolgenabschätzung des
Deutschen Bundestags nämlich bereits
untersuchungsanträge vor das
Interessante dabei diese Anträge kamen
nicht auf Initiative der Union sondern
die kamen auch von unserer Seite auf der
auf der Initiative der SPD wir die
Koalition ist es Sie diese
technologischen Entwicklungen
vollständig und Ideologie frei im Blick
hat